Company!
Welcome!
I like
the employees here.
Yeah, all my babies are cute.
I'm gonna have a good time at the company.
Yes, please!
Oh, I'm so nervous.
Banana!
I'll see that with the boom!
Oh, wow!
She's really good dancer.
Yeah.
Isn't this where you do a work?
You just dance?
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
Oh my gosh, they're so in sync.
Oh my gosh, yeah.
Should we do introductions?
Break free acid.
Yeah.
Who wants the call first?
Order.
Oh, oh, point, point.
Yes, you.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Luigi?
Do you have anything to say for yourself?
Hi, everyone.
It's me, Emily.
I'm a housewife V-tuber that plays the violin.
And in my free time, I take care of my niacama.
Nice to meet you.
Woohoo!
And yes, I'm Luigi.
I'm Luigi for this co-op.
I'm green.
Green man.
Green, sexy man.
Woohoo!
Green Nickel Man.
Hi.
Oh, me.
You.
Oh.
Hi.
I'm Ayla Coleman from Production Kawaii.
Should I do my intro?
Okay, Princess from Another World, VTuber, in your world.
Me?
My world?
No, your world.
Yeah.
Everybody's world.
It's my first time playing Lethal Company ever, so I'll do
my best not to die.
Yay!
Oh, they're great!
I believe in you!
Yay!
Let's go, we're in!
Alright, next up!
No!
I'm not good!
Oh, no!
What is you?
Why is you- I was- I was gonna point!
Oh my god!
I was gonna rob him.
I like Tokusatsu and I like hard games because I'm a
masochist.
I do silly challenges on my channel and that's it.
Yay!
I think you'll like this company if you're masochist.
Oh, true, true, true.
That's why I apply.
I've got a good CV.
Yo.
Big boss.
Um.
Hello.
My name is Mint Phantom.
I'm a ghost maid.
I'm here to suck the life force of others.
Everybody who I collab with.
And everybody who comes to my streams nice to meet uwu
can you suck my life force yeah yeah i i can hear this
please can i what can i what can you suck my life oh
live on stream live on stream It just kind of happens, you
know?
It's like, you know?
On the first day of work?
Oh my god.
It's a team building activity.
Yeah.
It's an icebreaker.
Yay.
That's everybody.
Oh my gosh.
This game.
Time to go to a first moon.
Wait, you have Mountain Dew.
As your...
Oh my gosh, yeah.
Your stuff is Mountain Dew.
Naki!
Really?
What is it called?
Oh my god!
Your backpack.
Yeah, you got bang.
You're a true gamer.
I trained that.
Oh, wow.
Gamer fuel.
How's my gamer juice?
Woohoo!
So, I, who, I, I'm scared of the mods we have in here.
I don't know what everything we've got.
Oh, this is scary.
We need her.
Oh, you.
There's also a big game update that I don't know anything
about.
Yeah, the game was just updated.
It's kind of crazy.
Yeah, actually some mods broke from it.
I know.
Later, ConK.
We were gonna try and have a...
Maybe Tord a harder mode.
Yeah.
We were gonna do a Minecraft mod, but it doesn't work.
Yeah, the Minecraft world.
Yeah.
So sad.
It's okay, though.
Yeah, new monsters, I think.
So I don't know anything about the new monsters, but that's
okay.
I'm scared, guys.
How do I- How do I- How do I sleep?
I shouldn't be on the computer.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know what I'm doing either, but- What moon do you
want to go to?
Anything!
The first one!
Yeah, maybe the first one.
Experimentation?
I don't know.
I think that's the first one.
First one!
Okay.
Yeah.
Do you know how to play?
Do you know what, like, we're doing?
Yeah, yeah, I have an idea.
Okay, okay.
I equip myself with basic knowledge.
Oh, she's got the knowledge.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Watch it.
100 lethal company tips.
100 lethal!
Did you?
I just didn't want to be carried.
I don't want to hold you guys back.
So I watched the 100 tips.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
Oh my gosh!
I tried to clap!
Wait, Maki, how did you know?
How did you know?
Yeah, yeah.
You know that we keep out of you?
I watched it too!
Wait, you guys are probably...
I watched monster deep dive video, like, I don't know,
explaining AI.
Yeah!
You're probably more professional than me.
I don't know!
I know it in theory.
I don't know how it works in practice.
Weird.
Well, we might have some gunk mechanics too, so I wouldn't
worry about the two mods.
Oh, really?
Oh, oh, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's like one mod.
Yeah.
Yeah, the present.
Oh, the present, that's right.
Gotcha, Laka.
You guys ready?
Naki, you take care of it.
Push the lever.
Let's go!
He's ready?
He wants to pull the lever.
Naki, you want to pull it?
Pull it, pull it, pull it, pull it, pull it.
Can't even, why can't I even touch your pressure?
Let's go.
Oh, actually, I don't know if we can pull it.
I can't.
Oh, really?
Oh, yeah, there's no option.
My bad.
Maybe it's just you, Emily.
I think it has to be me.
I need the trigger.
Whoopsie.
Then everything breaks.
Yeah.
Whoopsie.
Oh.
Then everything breaks.
Oh, what's going on?
There we go.
Oh!
Oh, yeah, you're supposed to scan things.
If you're close to it.
Hey, guys.
Oh!
You also showed me where the ship is.
In case you want to come back.
Yeah, in case I get lost.
Yeah.
Up here, up here, up here.
All right.
Here we go.
Dude, they're so fast.
Wow.
Here we go.
Oh.
Oh, it's gone.
It's gone.
Wait, not even going though.
Wait, I got some more.
Wait, wait, wait, where'd you guys go?
Where are they?
It's a seal.
It'll come down from the ceiling.
It's far away from us anyway.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Are you sure?
It won't hit us, yeah.
It's far away.
I don't know about...
Naki.
Oh my god.
I love you said it was far away.
We gotta go back!
I have her body!
Do we have anything?
We don't have anything.
We don't have...
Have her...
Ah!
Naki died too!
You have to get her body!
Okay, um, hold on.
How do I pick it up?
E!
Press E!
Yeah!
I'm
trucking you up, Naki!
I'm sorry!
No!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait!
I'll come over there!
We gotta put back Tori's body first!
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I can grab her body.
Can I try and get Naki's and I take Emory?
Alright, sure, sure.
How do I drop a body?
Okay, I got her.
I can't wait for me here.
Okay.
It's fine.
She knows the way back.
Emory, what happened?
Emory.
One second guys.
Would have been better if I died first.
What?
What do you mean?
I couldn't get her body.
Wait, I wonder what's wrong.
Maybe it's kind of bugged.
Yeah.
It's okay.
Let's just go grab a couple things and then we can leave.
Okay.
Don't die.
We got this.
We'll go the other way.
The other way, alright.
Yeah.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, this way?
Wait, who is this?
Wait, who's this?
Wait, no, there's Sheba, wait, you left your body!
No, no, I took her to the Sheba!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
We can get...
We gotta do bodies?
Um...
Oh my god.
What, what are we gonna do with this?
I don't know.
Wait, why do we have two of them?
Infinite money hack, maybe?
Here, I'm gonna...
Let's go check over here real quick and I'll see if there's
any items.
Alright, I'm ready.
Stay there.
Where are you?
Oh, there's nothing here.
It's empty completely.
Nothing you can grab?
Nope.
No.
They always just keep clicking right click and...
Oh, yeah.
Body of Emory.
Oh, what?
Wait, why is it red?
Oh, yeah, wasn't her thing?
Oh, it's green.
I'm like, still the same.
Oh, hmm.
The trap is over here.
Oh, here, here's a...
I got a thingy.
Oh, we're good.
We gotta follow you.
Okay, grab Emory.
Yeah.
Oh, Emory.
Let's grab her.
There we go.
Time to go back.
We got one thing so far.
Oh, we got two things.
We got an extra body.
You know, I wonder if we go back if she'll still be there
again.
Oh, right, right.
We got a chat.
Run, run, run, run.
Unlimited Emody works.
Oh!
Where did you place her body?
In here!
What?
I'm not crazy, you guys.
I'm not crazy.
Are you sure you got her body the first time?
I was holding her the whole time.
Ayla, I was holding her the whole time.
I promise.
It was in my head.
My chat.
Chat, we saw.
It's okay.
It wasn't your fault.
Ayla, no.
No, you believe me, right?
Yeah, yeah.
She was right here.
Come on.
Wait, also, I wonder...
This didn't...
This isn't picking up that I grabbed it.
Ding!
Oh!
Maybe it's because of the mod?
Maybe.
Um.
Should we just go?
It's almost five.
Oh.
Okay.
You want to try one more thing.
Try and get a little bit more stuff.
Alright.
I got one more.
More stuff?
Yeah.
Okay.
I think we need the money.
We're gonna have to run.
Let's go.
Alright.
We might all die.
Oh, no, no, no.
I'm going to be the first one for sure.
It's going to go back.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
It says near activity detected.
I think there's a monster right there.
I'll check.
Oh.
I don't remember this song.
What just happened?
I don't think she should...
Oopsie!
It was camping!
That's so unfair.
Oh my gosh, unfortunate.
Unfortunate!
I'm the lady, let's go!
Emory, how could you be- Yeah, practice run, guys.
We're fine.
The quota is only like $100.
Yeah, it's okay, we got this.
Yeah, we got this.
Yeah.
We learned our lesson now.
died so fast and i don't know what was going on with the
bodies uh i guess we'll see how i know wait i'm from grab
ducky's body from your screen yeah was i holding you yeah i
was you yeah no no you're holding ducky no yeah oh you're
hiding me yeah what that's so weird someone um in my chat
said i might have the gaslight mod installed but i don't
remember installing that
Yes, like, girl, boss mind.
Let my face.
Yeah.
Party.
Wow.
It's so good.
Oh, yeah.
Woohoo.
Let's go.
Oh, how fast everyone died.
The minion greedy.
Okay, we could do assurance.
Maybe.
Assurance.
Is that the second map?
Yeah.
Let's try it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Woohoo!
Let's go.
Okay, at least we got white before we got like a bunch of
loot.
Sneak.
I don't know where I'm stacking them.
I'm gonna rack in the money.
What if it's this mod breaking the game?
No way.
Oh yeah, I forgot to pass this.
Uh, worse, I think.
Here we go, Iquzo!
Iquzo!
Oh, oh, I love when they walk in place.
All right.
Everyone here?
Yeah!
Okay.
Iquzo!
Wait, I don't remember how to get to the...
What's the entrance?
I think it's...
I think it's this way.
Okay.
Follow Emily.
Oh wait, I think you're right.
Oh, no, I don't know.
This way.
I don't know.
What was that?
It was a...
You creature.
Ah!
What is that?
It's a snake.
I think he likes you.
Yeah.
Yeah, you can join it.
Wow!
It's so cute!
It's kind of fashionable.
Wait, is he loving your eyesight or?
Um, sometimes.
Sometimes.
Friend?
Okay.
It's okay.
He's my friend now.
I think it's a friend.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
As long as he's not killing you.
Yeah.
I'm gonna name him Henry.
Oh!
Henry!
It's on me.
Oh, there's a beehive.
Oh, no, there's so many Henrys.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they're called Henry?
Ah!
Oh, I just made it.
Oh, he's on me!
Oh, yeah.
Wait, wait, each have a Henrys now.
Wait, I have one?
I have someone.
You should join us.
Wait, I think I'm flying.
Guys, drive away!
Guys, I think I need help.
I think I need help.
Wait, you have two.
You have two of them.
I have two?
Yeah, you have two of them.
You have two.
Oh, there she goes!
Where'd she go?
Luigi, come home!
This is so fun.
Wait, how do we get inside?
Is it this way?
I think it's this way.
If I could actually control, you know?
This way?
Okay.
Yeah, this way, this way.
What is this?
These birds!
Oh wait, wait, wait, how do we get up?
Is it this way?
Oh, I think this way.
Yeah, yeah, this way, this way.
I want to fly!
Whoa!
Oh, here it is!
Here it is!
Yay!
I don't know what I'm doing either, but...
Will he come inside with me or...
I don't know.
Let's test it.
Will he?
Oh.
Is he inside?
Oh, he's inside with me!
Yeah, he is inside!
Oh.
Oh, there's an engine.
All right.
Let's play.
There you go.
Oh, there's an engine up there.
Yeah, there's an engine.
Oh, I got a cookie mold.
Oh, my hand is full already.
I got... I got Freeran!
Oh, I got Freeran!
I got Freeran!
Look how cute she is!
Look how collectible!
Oh my gosh, I got Freeran!
She's sweet!
She's so cute!
Oh my gosh.
I love the little sound effect.
Best mod ever.
Let's go.
I'm going to go look for this outside.
That's not key.
Check upstairs.
Anything?
Oh.
Oh, there's more cookie.
Easter.
Okay.
I'm full.
La la la.
Need to watch that.
Yeah, it's so good.
Is there something down there?
There's what?
That's my handbrain.
He left.
fifth bye he loved me next
oh there's a cat oh my god there's just a cat in there let's
go oh my god okay he doesn't have a name oh he's so cute oh
he's getting back the cat cute can we oh what what did you
do with him yeah let's take him home let's take him home
yeah all right let's take our loot all right here we go
let's take our loot my hands are full yeah yeah how do we
get home how do i use this flat oh my gosh okay jump no i
just hear the cat meowing it's so cute oh it's a curvy oh
sorry that was that was that was a knocky never mind i'm the
menu i'm the menu i'm the menu I think it's this way.
I'm scanning.
Scanning?
ABS, always be scanning.
Oh!
Oh, it's there.
I hope Naki's okay.
I thought I saw it come out.
Oh my gosh!
There could be birds!
Is there actually a beehive here?
Or...
No.
There's not a beehive.
ABS, always be silly.
Always be silly.
All right.
Loot!
Yay!
Free run!
Oh my gosh!
I don't know what happened.
What happened?
We had a bit of a...
There was like a little confetti explosion.
Oh yeah.
the cat oh my gosh i'm gonna take him good kitty wait how do
i flip oh oh i'm pet the cat yeah we should go check on pet
the cat okay let's go what's the cat's name um it should say
when we scan but i can't see i think his name is just cat
it's not around the area it's just oh it's kitty
Or I will look for nunchies.
Yeah, let's go, let's go.
Yeah, yeah.
Uh-oh.
It's 5 p.m.
I think that was a worm.
Wasn't that a worm?
Uh-oh.
Oh, I don't like worms.
Maybe not.
I...
Okay, a fly don't have anything.
She's back!
Oh, okay, good, good, good, good.
Oh, oh, oh.
She's alive!
I don't...
I can't find anything!
Bracken was keeping its mind and its eyes on me.
You had the Bracken?
Oh, the Freeland Blushy is so cute.
Isn't it cute?
We're collectible.
On the way back, I was trained by worms, yeah?
Be a worm for you, girl.
Yeah, I wanna go?
Yeah, we can go.
I think we've got a lot of loot.
All right, let's go.
Let's go before we die.
Oh, wait, I forgot to select her.
Yeah, maybe I did see this.
I thought it was active.
Or moon.
I was hearing you guys' voices in there.
You heard us, but we weren't in there?
Yeah!
That's so scary.
You're here, right?
I thought you came back.
But no.
That was probably the Bracken imitating you.
That's so scary!
Oh, was the skinwalker doing its thing?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, I think it's imitating your voice.
Ew!
Ew, ew, ew.
Okay.
Alright, let's go get some new stuff.
baby all right yeah I do this right I don't want to sell
free room oh yeah okay so we need to pick a new moon yeah we
need to get lots of stuff we can keep free yeah we got to
get lots of stuff we can keep free room you want to go with
adamant no I can hear oh the cow is here yeah go pick
whatever okay okay
Pet that cat.
Oh my god.
The way you have to flip him over is so weird.
Yeah, sit in the corner, cat.
Sit in the corner.
Oh, he's so cute.
Yeah.
He can buy cat food for him, right?
I'm not sure what cat food.
Oh yeah, you can.
You can.
We forgot about shopping.
We can buy like flashlights.
No, we don't need flash.
Oh, we don't have money yet though.
Yeah, I don't think we have money actually.
Oh yeah, we only have 20.
So we might be able to buy cat food.
Let me check.
Cat food 5.
Do we have 5?
Yeah, we have 20.
Buy cat food!
Try emoting with the cat.
Am I emoting?
No.
It doesn't work, I think.
Oh.
Yay!
It's working!
My son ever again!
Wait, what am I doing the crazy?
Yay!
Oh, come here.
Oh.
Here, we'll get you there.
We can put it on the table!
Look, we may be broke, but we need cat food.
Did you buy it?
Yeah, I did.
How much was it?
Um, it was five.
Okay, so let's land and then we can grab it.
I love it.
Kitty-gritty.
So good.
An ice cream machine.
Miu.
Let's go baby.
Where is this?
Oh.
Oh, the ice cream machine gonna land here.
I've never been here before.
Oh, is this new?
I think this is a new one.
Hmm.
Oh, is the map.
Oh Oh, I know is there still not bridge is this the bridge
that's well?
Yeah, I don't know wait I don't think so.
Oh, yeah, we gotta get the ice cream.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah Where's the drop though?
I don't know
It's just in the air
Watch out for the lake Oh, there it is.
Oh, I hear it!
Where is it?
Where?
This way?
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
Oh, it's here!
Oh, I got it!
Retrieve the cat poop!
Uh-oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
This
way.
This way.
Yeah.
Come around.
Alright.
Gather round.
round how do i feed him oh wait hold on please sit down hold
on oh okay we eat it maybe it's picky oh there we go oh oh
gosh is he he's not why is he ignoring you it's really wet
point it oh pick the cat come on cat eat eat eat eat eat
Eat!
Wow, this looks very annoying.
Yeah, he's like, why are you trying to force me to eat?
This isn't even my favorite flavor.
Eat!
Oh, oh, oh.
I think the audio just like...
It did for me too.
Maybe it'll be gone.
Maybe he's shy.
It'll be gone when we get back.
Maybe he needs like... Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Keep him alone.
Alright.
Let's go!
I think I heard it crack a little you I think it's gonna
fall it looks a little unstable just like me all right you
go one at a time okay next person next next next come on
over come on over I think he can run.
It should be fine.
Yeah, it looks a little unstable.
I think it's okay though.
Yeah.
There should be an alternative way, though.
There's kind of...
Yeah, there has to be somewhere, right?
Yeah.
Okay, I think we can stop.
Loot,
loot, loot, loot.
Whoa.
We gotta keep the free Randall.
Oh, egg beater.
Egg beater.
Um, um, um, yes.
Oh.
Oh, um, oh, what?
I think that's a thumbs up.
I think it was where we were at.
Let's go the other way.
Yeah, I think we should not go that way.
Um, um, why is it getting down there?
What?
Maybe it's on another floor.
I think we're okay.
Oh, weapon.
The stop sign.
No, I just have to go.
Are you guys alive?
Yeah?
Oh, it's just dying!
Oh my god!
Oh, that almost scared me!
Oh, that's...
Oh, it's upside!
Nice!
Wait, we got it!
Let's go this way!
Okay, I think we'll be okay.
I don't have anything.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, let's...
I think we'll be fine.
I need to grab something.
Anything in here?
Hello?
I have empty hands.
It's pretty...
Oh!
I think I just saw the thumper go by.
Oh, yes, I just saw him.
I just saw him go.
Oh, my gosh.
So what?
Yeah, the thumper.
That monster?
Oh, my God.
Yeah, I think maybe.
I think so.
Maybe we should go.
Yeah, maybe we, yeah.
It's impressive.
Um.
Oh, what?
I think we can go.
Do you finally see the monster in there?
Yeah, we saw him around.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Maybe we can find the other entrance.
Maybe it's like down here.
That's another entrance?
There usually is.
Oh.
Fire exit?
That's...
Yeah.
Oh, watch out for the...
Is that the beehive?
Yeah, that's the actual beehive.
Watch out.
Beehive.
Oh.
Um...
Oh, there's another house here.
It's the house.
Oh, yeah.
Let's check that out.
Whoa.
Oh, it's lost.
Oh, I have a key.
Oh, try, try, try.
Nice.
Oh.
Oh, there's nothing here.
There's art.
It says something on the wall.
Sixier art.
A profound message.
I got it.
Art.
Sixier.
There is nothing here.
Heart.
What does that mean?
One away from greatness.
I know.
Hmm.
Are you going back or are you going back in?
Oh, what is that?
Is that a...
What is this?
What?
Oh, those guys are annoying.
Stay away.
Oh!
I think they can't even come down.
It's probably...
Oh, I heard the cat.
Wait, did the cat come all the way over here?
I don't think so.
Maybe there's another cat.
Oh.
Uh... It's getting dark.
It is starting to get dark.
I don't know the way back, though.
I think it's just up here, right?
Yeah, there it is.
Right there.
Oh!
Oh,
how do I get up?
Wait, how do we get up?
How do I get up?
I go under the bridge, yeah.
Oh, go, go, go!
I think you just gotta yell at them and they go away, right?
Oh, really?
I think so.
They don't like noise, right?
Wait, was someone alive?
Was someone alive?
Wait!
We still have our cat!
Oh no, they weren't allowed.
Who was I hearing?
Oh, Skinwalker maybe.
Oh, maybe, yeah.
Yay!
I lost my son.
Wait, Emily, are you talking?
I can't hear you.
Did you accidentally mute?
I'm like...
You had two days left to meet...
We lost the cat, too.
No, I can hear him, I can hear him.
He's outside.
Cat?
He got killed?
I feel like the cat could die.
Maybe he's dead.
Oh, hello?
Oh, there you go!
Hello?
Okay, what did he do?
Okay, my mic cut out for some reason.
He should be good.
Yeah, probably something bugged it.
Do you know how we get to the company?
Oh, let me see.
audio glitch yeah I thought the cat died I saw blood inside
that was my blood that was my blood wait where is the cat
but also
are you sure yeah he did you're sure it's not the voices in
your head no I promise oh I promise oh company confirm
company building time to set oh
Oh.
Wait.
Is it Gordy?
Oh, this is where the company resides, yeah.
I think we might have lost the cat.
No!
No, we didn't lose him!
I promise he's right outside these doors!
Cat!
Really?
Wait!
Did they eat the food?
Yeah.
What's food?
What the heck?
Um...
He's upstairs.
He's up here.
They must be really hungry.
I...
Oh, Tyler's not here.
Everyone?
Oh, I don't see Kenny.
What?
I heard him!
See?
I hear him!
Yeah, I... He's somewhere!
I don't think he's delusional?
What?
See?
You all need to... You need to take your meds too!
It's not just me!
It's you!
Take your meds, everybody!
He's in our wall.
Oh, there he is!
There he is!
Where is he?
Oh, gosh!
Where?
Is he inside the...
I'm where?
Um...
Where is this pious peacock?
Did he dip?
What is his food?
Is he invisible?
It's empty.
A scan.
Oops.
Where is he?
It might be invisible.
Hmm.
Kenny?
Where is he?
I think we're going crazy.
Are you under the ship?
It's you, Emily.
It's your...
your cat ears my cat ears you are you are yying without
knowing that you're doing it oh my gosh it's a ghost cat
it's my cat for real all right let's sell should we keep the
free room plushy all the food is gone yeah wait it's eating
the food ate the food
the biggest mystery Did you eat the food?
No, sorry guys, it was me.
I got a little hungry.
It was very yummy!
Why is he eating the food even?
I don't know if I could sell it.
Oh, can we sell it?
Oh, sell the can.
Oh, they're the egg beater too.
How much does this sell for?
Ah!
Sorry, I, uh...
I scared myself.
What did he say?
He said you have been valuable to the company.
Oh.
I dare you.
Why is he not getting the item?
Oh my god.
How did you live?
How someone lived?
That spooked me earlier too.
Cookie sheet?
Oh, you're right!
I know I have a cookie sheet.
You're right.
Thanks, guys.
Oh, okay.
How much did we get?
Good eye.
Did you reach the quota?
Higher profit.
Did you have to sell Freeman?
We don't?
We can keep Freeman.
Yippee!
We keep her.
Yeah, we reach the quota though.
Oh, yeah!
Let's go!
Good job!
Just barely.
Oh my god.
Yay!
First day at the company.
Good job, everybody.
Good job.
Oh, oh, oh, he's good job.
I don't know where our cat is, but he'll come home.
I think the cat turned into a ghost.
I think so too, honestly.
Is that possible?
You don't see him under here.
Wait, wait, I heard him.
I heard him just now.
Oh, really?
Over here.
Cat.
Oh, I see him!
He's up here!
He's coming!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Watch!
Look!
He's coming!
Oh my god!
Can we get him?
Wait, wait!
I got him!
Yay!
Cat!
Where are you?
We saved him!
Down!
Oh my god.
Aw, that's okay, Kat.
Invisible tree.
You're safe now.
Okay, now, oh my gosh.
Okay, now, oh my gosh, can you imagine if we left?
He would have been stuck there.
Yeah.
That would have been so sad.
Okay, good lady.
Maybe we should put him inside here.
Oh, true, true, true.
Yeah, put him in there.
Nice.
Oh, there, lock him in.
Oh my God.
Good, good, good.
I think that works.
Yeah, I think so.
It worked, it worked.
It worked.
Just a grab.
Okay.
Put him in there.
There we go.
His butt is a bit down.
This is humane.
Yeah.
Just to keep him safe, you know?
It is, it is, it is.
I don't think the computer likes me.
It opens.
Do we have money?
We have money!
We can buy flashlights!
I don't need flashlights!
No flashlight?
No!
I don't need a flashlight.
Okay, we're gonna put a name flashlight.
I need this flashlight.
I don't know.
Oh, wait!
We could get a...
What are they?
called spray paint 70 off oh what a deal let's go yeah i
love the one sale even if i don't need it i want it yeah
sale sale sale sale sale sale okay i'm gonna get spray paint
for everyone so we can have one yeah let's go vandalism all
right vandalism i'm waiting i'm waiting I know it's coming.
I think I just heard the cat meow.
I'm waiting.
Oh, oh, oh, what is that?
The drop ship?
Shake can.
I can't grab it.
Shake it.
And shake it off.
Why can't I grab it?
Oh, I think I need to crouch.
Oh.
There we go.
Nice.
Run out.
Come here, Amori.
Come here.
Whoa.
Are you drawing on me?
It doesn't work.
Are you run out of paint or no?
I don't know, actually.
I don't think you run out of it.
I think the mod left you.
Ooh, they are different color.
Oh, if you press T, you can change color.
Oh.
Yeah.
And you can press E to erase, I think.
E?
Yeah, E to erase.
You have to hold it, though.
Oh, right.
E for erase.
This is the most massive.
It's so damn!
Oh my gosh.
We can...
Oh, you could only fit Sam.
I couldn't fit Samma.
I could only fit Sam.
I love Sam.
I think you have to shake it too.
Oh my gosh.
That doesn't look like a dress.
How do you change your color again?
Oh, T.
T.
Press T.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, uh, shake.
Oh my god, it's spooky.
Man.
Oh.
Cute.
It's fun.
Whoa.
Splatoon!
Oh, wait!
Oh my gosh, I shake my hand.
you are not close enough there we go should i draw you guys
say shake shake what should i draw woo me oh i know
ready for this now ready for this there's no
Ow.
Oh my gosh, it's so cute.
Cute.
Oh wow, my handwriting looks like this.
Rebel!
Um, I'm gonna, oh, uh...
I also am a rebel.
Oh, yeah, school.
Oh, look, yellow.
Not good.
I'm trying to draw like a cat.
I don't think it's working.
I think you have to shake it.
Or you get closer.
Oh, nice.
Sucks.
Size.
Oh, how do I...
How do I change the size?
School sucks So cute Oh wait Oh fuck Oh my god What is that?
It's supposed to be a ghost It's supposed to be a ghost
Emily, Emily Emily, follow me, follow me Okay, okay One hour
Oh?
Where did she fall in my neck?
This is a very
bustling What the heck?
Is this one having the same personality type does?
I think so.
Oh.
Oh my god.
How vulgar.
Graffiti, graffiti, graffiti, graffiti.
Oh man.
I'm gonna make it worse.
I wanted this to be fair to see.
Yeah, will this still be here when we come back?
Poopy, poopy.
Oh, poopy, poopy.
Whoa, that might get you, it's spelled from school.
I know, I hope so.
Oh, actually, I know what else I can draw.
She has so much power.
I keep dropping my pen.
Eyes, they're staring at you.
Oh my gosh.
What are you drawing?
I drew a smiley face.
He's wearing big glasses.
He's a nerd.
Nerd.
This looks like a flower.
What's that?
That doesn't look right.
I'm going to erase it.
Wow.
Cute.
Oh, it's so cute.
Let's go to the pee people.
Yeah, give it angry brown.
Angry.
Wow.
He likes vandalism.
You're like a prisoner.
I can't breathe too short.
This is real vandalism.
Emory.
Is...
Uh oh.
Oh, I can vandalize this card.
Oh my god.
Your office looks better now, I think.
Vandalism, vandalism!
No.
Aww.
Can I
ask?
Someone wrote something so mean about you.
For the company.
I knew the nerd glasses.
The nerd glasses actually.
This is too long!
Comple.
Are you guys comfortable?
Is our cat still in our locker?
Yeah, I think the cat's meowing.
Oh yeah, he's still in there.
It's all good.
Emu-y is a nerd.
It's a compliment.
He's bullying me.
SpeedTubers are...
Are?
Cringer.
Cring?
Cring!
No way there!
No!
Cringer!
Oh my god.
True.
So real.
So true.
True.
Trill, trill, trill.
VTubers are cringe.
VTubers are criminals.
Wow, this is so fun.
Look at us.
Look at us go.
Oh, wow.
You can even go in here?
Wait.
He won't get me.
He can't get me.
I don't think.
I could see.
smell the paint.
I know, right?
It reeks in here.
No, I'm trying to draw the best bud of my life, but I think
I made it two points.
It's a peach?
Is that an eggplant?
Yeah.
There's a peach.
Peach and...
It's like an apple.
What is she drawing?
What is she cooking?
Is that a bite?
Yes!
Oh my god.
Next to the peach.
ground oh and school ground okay okay i'm not gonna get
fired for this right they won't know oh gorgeous we gotta
boost morale yeah yeah
oh no oh no i want to rush have space never mind please oh
where is chad I'm cooking.
No, I'm not cooking anymore.
I'm bad at cooking.
She's cooking.
Oh, it's dark here.
I can't even see what I'm drawing.
I can see a little.
I'm going to try to draw there, but...
I'll draw here.
Oh, I can't.
Oh, yeah, I can't see this one.
I don't know.
Wait, how do I...
How do you erase it again?
Uh, E.
You have to hold E and spur.
E.
Mm-mm.
Oh, my God.
Among Us?
Oh.
I thought it was a mong...
Here I'll do it.
It's very cute though.
Oh my gosh.
Sush.
wow well did you guys enjoy the break yeah yeah i hope it
all i hope it all stays when we come back yeah hopefully the
janitor where did that emery go is she not on earth now wait
where'd emery go where'd it go i didn't race it's fading
it's fading away oh no way oh my god it's all gone oh i'm
not a nerd anymore i want to see it disappear i'm gonna
watch um spray it is disappearing yeah i was gonna say it's
the opposite of watching paint dry it's watching paint
disappear dry and disappear yeah man disappear disappear
performance anxiety yeah you gotta appreciate graffiti while
you can Yeah, the janitors are so quick here.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, it disappeared before my very eyes.
Oh, I think the more you use the spray paint, it will
disappear.
Oh, is that one?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, man.
Wow.
That's how it works.
Oh, there it goes.
It doesn't even say, nerd.
It just says, erd.
Erd.
There we go.
No.
Ah!
Nothing.
Nierd!
There we go.
Oh, no, no, no!
Nierd.
All right.
All right, okay.
Okay, well, hopefully it's there when we come back.
Yeah, we'll see you, I guess.
All right.
You guys ready for next mission?
Yeah!
You guys are so fun.
She's so cute.
Oh!
How did it get so big?
Oh my gosh, we could draw inside.
This is interior decorating.
For the company.
For the company!
We need some art.
Our cat is green!
oh really
there we go
radioactive radioactive
radioactive child yeah let's see this is all my safety
standards whoa oh my gosh I'm so like colorful it looks like
it looks like holographic should we light It's true.
Go to experimentation.
Oh, what is there?
There's experimentation, assurance, adamance, rend, dine.
The rest are like flooded or rainy or foggy.
Uh, okay.
We could try experimentation again.
Experimentation?
Since we died last time.
I don't think we've seen Goku yet, right?
No, we haven't.
No, Goku, yeah.
Wait, oh, it must be...
Oh, we have to leave.
No, bracket, but it was not Goku.
Goal is to meet Goku.
Goku, Goku, Goku, Goku, Goku, Goku.
Must manifest Goku.
Oh my god, the cat is beautiful.
Oh my god.
It was beautiful.
Now we can go, I think.
Hi.
Did we ever buy flashlights or...
Oh, no.
We spent...
Yeah, you can.
Yeah, we're all like, we don't need flashlight.
I think I can just press serious.
We don't need flashlight.
Here we go!
Let's go!
I wanna hear Goku.
I'm gonna, you know what?
I'm gonna run around inside.
I think the catch is very...
Nothing will stop me.
Oh, shiny.
All right.
We land?
We landing?
Where are we landing, boys?
Oh!
What was that?
Kiss, kiss, free Rin, good luck!
Yeah, kiss free, free, good luck!
For good luck, for good luck!
Yeah, for good luck.
Free Rin, some bless our, bless our journey.
Um...
Uh...
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Uh, what?
Uh...
What?
Yeah?
Why is it eclipsed?
An eclipse?
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, close the door, close the door!
I think he's coming closer.
You're stuck.
It didn't say Eclipsed?
Yeah.
I think we can go.
He's on the back of the...
He's on the back.
I think we can go.
We just gotta be quiet.
Just be quiet.
Yeah, just be quiet.
He's expecting me.
Is it not picking you up?
It was cracking me up.
Oh my god.
Oh, what was that?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
What was that?
I heard something.
Oh, no.
What was that?
Oh.
It's a little dark.
Nothing there.
Watch your step.
Keep scanning.
I don't see anything else.
Me neither.
I don't see a place to walk, so...
I guess we go back.
But the other way...
Was that the Bracken in the beginning?
Maybe.
That sound that we heard?
But the Bracken should say, hey, it's me, Goku.
Oh, you're right.
But I said Bracken.
Hey, it's me, Goku.
It's me, Goku.
There's nothing.
Oh, there's a flask.
Oh, opening...
Grab the flask.
Grab it.
Ooh, can you drink it?
Sound kind of wet.
Oh, nice.
Nope.
Oh.
The door sounds scary.
The door is so scary.
Calm.
Okay.
Oh, it's dead end.
There's not a lot here.
Lala.
I think we gotta go to the other side.
Yeah.
The other side.
This one is really big though.
Oh, yeah.
spider here not really goku
oh another door yeah hello hello hello oh oh steering wheel
yeah nice nice oh there's one more more stuff nice nice Oh,
you got a key?
No, it's metal sheet.
Oh, metal sheet.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a...
Well, let's turn it on or off.
Oh.
Wait, what's supposed to happen?
I don't know, actually.
Goku.
I think we're all good here.
I think we're all good, yeah.
I think we have one more item.
Yeah, me too.
I have enough for one more.
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay, that's the exit right there.
Uh-huh.
Oh, there's...
Oh, what's that?
I think that was a Pacifica walker!
I don't think that was a friend!
I think it's close.
Should we...
Yeah.
Okay.
This is the...
Yeah.
Okay, here we go.
Remember the dogs.
Dogs are bad.
Yeah.
In this game.
Oh.
Where's the...
We just so?
Oh.
Um, I think he's on the ship.
Oh, yeah.
There's a lot.
There's two of them.
They're on the ship.
So, who are they attacking?
Safe to.
They're attacking someone.
I think it's the cat.
No.
I think we can go now.
Oh yeah.
Wait, wait, wait.
It sounded like you.
It sounded...
Really?
No!
Why did it get me?
I
gotta get...
Oh my god!
No!
We lost everything!
Oh, Freeran!
I like had it and then they got me.
Yeah, what the heck?
So rude.
I got the, it gave me like the Metal Gear like death scene
though.
It did, it did.
Okay.
Really?
Mm-hmm.
Oh my gosh.
Man.
Yeah, everybody died the end.
We didn't know that it was, it didn't say Eclipse though
when I picked it.
It didn't change.
Yeah, the odds were up also.
I forgot to put my spray can here.
I can't put show shine.
You can have mine, it's okay.
You can have mine.
You can have mine too, yeah, yeah.
It's okay, it's okay.
Okay, now it says Eclipse.
Wow.
They lied to us.
What is Vow?
I've never... You gaslit us.
Is Vow good to go to?
a new one.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll try Vow.
As long as it's not a cleric or a bad letter.
Yeah.
Oh, we don't have a lot of money left.
Uh-oh.
We have a lot of money.
We can get more money.
Yeah.
Yeah, we'll just get more money.
I'll just Vow.
We lost our cat, Eva.
This is so sad.
I think there's a lot of cats, though.
We can find another cat.
Yeah.
I found another liner.
Also killed us, though.
We gotta be killed.
I can see the dog charging us.
Let's let...
Oh.
Land.
Oh, Titan's good for beginner.
It is?
Titan is good.
I think they're trolling.
Yeah, I don't know about that.
Yeah, you go moonwalking Luigi.
You go moonwalking Luigi.
Yeah.
Moonwalk?
Yeah, this is normal.
This is normal.
Titan easy?
It should be safer.
Titan's oddies.
Wait, is it this way, right?
This way?
Is this a new map?
This is fine.
This one?
Yeah, I think this one's old.
Don't follow me!
I don't know where I'm lost!
Clear!
Oh wait!
I don't know where I'm going!
I found it!
Oh, yeah!
Okay, okay, okay.
We have to walk across the bridge.
Yeah, this one's the concrete one.
Everybody can go.
This is the concrete one, okay.
Yeah.
Oh, it's not the back door.
It's right here.
Wait, where is it?
Wait, wait a minute.
Where's the door?
Oh, it's right here, right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But would I scan?
It doesn't show up.
Weird.
Oh!
Ducky!
I'm done.
Ducky, Ducky.
I wonder what else there's around.
Nothing here.
Actually nothing here.
Mito!
Hi!
Where are you?
There's nothing down there.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's the yippee!
Yippee!
Something attacked me?
What?
It's a yippee bug.
Yeah, it's the yippee bug.
Yippee!
I love, I love a yippee bug.
Actually, I hate the yippee bug.
But I love the yippee.
Oh, this is also dead end.
Toilet?
I was like, toilet!
I was like, I don't remember putting in the Skippity Toilet
mod.
I'm scared for a second.
Whoa!
Oh, I thought it was a toilet too!
Yeah!
Something's seaming.
Yeah, we have to turn it off somewhere.
Yeah, there should be a valve.
Oh, is that it?
No.
Find it?
I can't find it.
Hi!
It's so dark!
Where am I?
It's his arm!
Yippee!
Oh jeez!
It's really dark!
Wait.
What?
No yippee!
Are they okay?
I think we should go.
Oh my god.
No yippee!
I
found its nest.
He won't know that I'm holding onto that right?
Where are you?
Oh!
Out!
Out.
Oh, where am I?
Okay, you can have it!
You can have it!
Hello?
Uh...
I think that's a...
That's a skinwalker.
That's gotta be a skinwalker.
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah.
Wait, no.
Where is this?
Naki's all by yourself!
I'll let you lock.
Naki is all by herself.
Eevee!
Oh!
Uh-oh.
She found my body!
Wait, I can finally see myself.
I've never seen the boss or the big boss.
Wait!
Naki, I'm right there!
Naki, notice me!
Naki!
Uh-oh.
Naki, you're gonna die!
Naki!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
That's a bracken!
Goddammit!
Is everyone going on me?
That's crazy!
You just love me, I guess.
I don't know how to go back.
I'm gonna have to go to the Bracken.
Not Goku.
I wonder if the Goku mod is broken.
Yeah, creatures really love me.
That's me.
Does she not see me?
That is...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh!
Wait a minute.
Can we pass this?
Oh, bring her back.
Oh my god, I can't tell if that's actually the the skim
walker or not.
Got her?
No!
Wait, actually...
No, I can't hear their voice.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, they can't tell either.
There's so many of you!
No, no, no, I'm not looking at you.
I'm not looking at you.
Naki!
I had your body!
I know, I saw.
Oh, it's locked.
I can use the key though.
Okay.
You...
You were actually hearing them.
They were hearing you.
but everyone thought it was a skim walker.
What?
Really?
Yeah.
I think so at least.
There's a room here.
I got yippies.
I also hear yourself.
Cookie mold pin.
Where are those items?
Okay.
I got cookie mold pin.
I would have died if I didn't run into so many of the yippie
bugs.
I know there's so many.
Oh, there's an item back there.
They're so random.
Would I make the jump though?
Jump.
Oh no.
Parkour.
I will risk my life.
I could drop my items that I could try.
Okay.
Go, Amari.
But what if you die?
And I'm gonna be alone.
What if you die?
That's funny.
Eevee.
I'll go.
It's okay.
Yeah!
Fire, core.
Okay, okay.
Now I just have to make it back.
Wait, what is on that side?
Now maybe I can jump to you and maybe there's like a next
one.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, true to do.
Okay, you can do it.
You can do it.
Just be careful.
Yeah, grab the items.
I don't know.
Yeah.
i feel like that too do i jump do i jump um just just get on
the ledge i think you could just walk onto it oh yeah yeah
and then um do a dash jump behind my drivers i'm not on
there i know ah gamer all right gamer that was so close
really dark maybe we navigate out of the place uh where
should the window no i don't think so we just jump again i
don't know i think oh there's a plastic fish in here.
Oh, my hand's in the logo.
There's so many things.
Yeah, yeah, I can grab that.
Nice.
Maybe there's a door up there.
Where did we come from?
We came.
Maybe we should go back that way, but I'm too scared to jump
again.
I think it's hard to come back.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
Okay.
Do it.
I'm going to jump.
Okay.
No, I think your loot is valuable, so I should jump.
Okay, you can try.
They're talking as if you're dying already.
I know.
You got this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We are done.
Okay.
Do it.
For the company!
Oh, nice, nice.
Okay, game.
Now it's right there.
Okay.
For the company!
Woohoo!
Yeah!
Let's go back.
Yeah.
Gamers.
Yeah, we've got a lot of items.
I wonder what time it is.
I feel like...
Yeah, I think that item is very valuable.
Where did we come from?
Did we come from down or this way?
Oh, I don't think there's anything crazy out there.
I don't think we came from...
Yeah, we came from the...
Yeah, downstairs, yeah.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh, yeah, we came through here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We unlocked the door, yeah.
Here and then...
Okay, I found it, I found it.
Oh, well, they have a fire exit!
Wait, is it the real fire exit?
Oh!
It's real, it's real.
Oh, now it's real.
How do I get back up?
Yeah.
I'll figure it out.
I got this.
They got this.
I miss.
I can't see the timer.
Oh, neither.
It doesn't say.
Oh, it's just a tree.
No, not that way.
I'm going to the other way.
I'm going to...
There's water.
Water, water, water.
Oh, it's flooded.
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
Oh, up here?
Let's go back to the bridge, maybe.
I mean, it looks like man, but different colors.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my god.
We take the concrete bridge or the other one.
Oh my gosh, it's so dark.
Okay, let's take the car.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, just follow.
Yeah, yeah, there you go.
I don't see any giants.
They're okay.
Okay.
Three more stairs.
But it's foggy.
It's really foggy.
It's dark.
Okay, it is foggy.
Oh boy.
I don't see anything.
Where's the ship?
Oh, no.
I don't know.
It's over here.
Found it.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, okay.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
Oh.
Okay.
What?
There's like no monsters.
It's crazy.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Very, very lucky.
Yeah, super lucky.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Um, since, since Naki and Mint aren't here, I think, uh,
they might not be back.
Yeah, yeah.
Why did I do a sewer now?
Go, go, go, there's a giant!
They didn't get their bodies either.
Yeah, it's okay.
Yeah, I can hear him walking.
Oh, yeah, okay, okay, I can hear.
it's it's late anyway we gotta go mrd managed to avoid the
round i don't know is she showing you what the heck did that
no i didn't see it saw something big oh probably was the
giant oh did it lie oh they did oh they died amazing yeah
not so bad you guys carry you guys are so good Yeah!
I'm so nervous!
Okay.
Glad we got something.
What did you guys die to?
I got, we both died to the Yippie Bug.
Oh, you did?
The Yippie Bug and the Kraken.
Yeah.
Oh, did you know the Spinwalker copied your voice?
It was like, Yippie!
Really?
Yeah, your voice!
Yippie!
I'm gonna make it to the quarter?
It's an increase.
Alright.
I think we'll be okay.
Oh.
Let's try our best.
One day left.
I'm gonna go to Adamant.
Yeah.
We can sell our spray cans if we need to and stuff.
Oh, okay.
All right.
High five, Ayla, Samma.
High five.
How do you high five?
I don't know.
We can have a point instead.
Good point.
Touch fingers.
Clap at you.
Yeah.
E.T.
touches.
Oh, yeah, I got a...
Oh, sorry.
All right, here we go.
Let's go!
I believe it's copying my voice.
I drink water.
I thought I was gonna die from falling.
I'm so glad.
Wait, what?
Oh, are we back?
Yeah.
All right.
Let's go.
Oh, where is it?
I think the first time I nailed that jump, like, back and
forth without dying.
to go up that thing.
Oh, okay.
What is that?
Oh, I think this...
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, it scared me!
It's this thing again.
You can fly now.
It's dragging you right here.
Fly me across!
Nope.
Come on over.
The water's fine.
Nice.
Hey.
Oh, I'm not here.
I'm right now.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
She's flying around.
Am I actually flying?
I think it was.
Yeah.
More than one to fly.
Oh.
It's so cool.
Whoa.
Here we go.
Alright, we should go around.
Oh, I like two.
Oh, there's something here.
Oh, oh- Oh, oh, there- What?
It's the guy, it's the guy.
Freddie Fazbear!
I'm Freddy Fazbear!
Oh my God, I'm Freddie Fazbear!
Oh.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I like those guys.
They're fun.
We found Freddy.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, is that him?
Did someone grab Freddy?
Oh, there's an item here.
Yeah.
Oh, a horse.
A horse.
I don't think there's anything else.
Nah, it's empty.
Why I have to go another way?
It's just me.
This is you.
It's Freddy Fazbear.
Freddy Fazbear.
I got a present!
Gotcha!
Wait.
I gotta do it here.
I'm gonna wait for the question.
Naki?
I see.
All right.
I got you.
Oh, it's that thing again.
Just hug the wall.
Hug the wall.
Be careful.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Oh, be careful.
At least it's life this time, you know?
Hug the wall.
Yeah.
Oh, gotcha.
It's copying your voice.
We should open...
Wait, I don't know.
Maybe we should open outside.
We should open outside.
I heard the skim walker.
Come on, guys.
Alrighty.
Happy birthday to us!
It's about!
Oh, nice, yeah.
That's what I love.
Let's go.
Let's go!
I only...
Alright.
Can we bring it back on the ship?
Yeah we can take our stuff back for now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
Alright, maybe pass.
I know.
I love that you're horrid.
Did you think she's good?
Alright.
.
Oh, it's this thing again.
Oh, we're in.
I hope this doesn't explode.
Oh, thank goodness.
Okay.
Wait, where's Freddy?
Where's Freddy?
Oh, I don't know who has Freddy.
I got her.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Okay, I think we're good.
Freddy Fazbear is worth how much?
That guy's priceless.
Oh, Airhorn is 60.
Wow.
I think we're good.
We did already.
I think we can go back in though.
It's still kind of earlier.
Oh, okay.
Sorry, sorry.
My bad.
Oh!
Hold on, I'll try going.
Um, Come here, come here.
Oh, I took some damage.
Me too.
I took damage also.
I think we just gotta...
Yeah, I think you just gotta take it.
Just gotta run past him.
Oh, is this a jump?
No, no, no, no.
I'm not doing it again.
Hey, go.
Wait, shoot.
He's got shoo.
Shoo.
Guys, okay?
Shoo, shoo.
Shoo, shoo, shoo.
Get off me, ah!
Okay, let's go back inside before we...
Okay, let's go!
I think so!
Ready to go earlier?
I think it went there.
I don't remember.
Did they die?
I
think so.
Do you think they died?
I think so.
Let's just go back.
Okay.
Going back inside was a mistake!
Go away!
Go away, we're trying to go home!
Away from the bridge, away from the bridge.
I think everybody died.
No!
Oh my
god, we shouldn't have gone backwards.
We shouldn't have...
I think we're 12.
I think we're fine.
Yeah, it's only 12.
I think it's fine.
We'll just sell Freddy Fazbear for a guy.
Yeah, Freddy's worth a lot, and so is a bow.
No, the air horns are worth 60, so I think we can...
Yeah, I think we're good.
Yeah, whoa!
Really?
Wow.
Yeah, yeah.
We have two air horns, so that's 120 already.
Yeah, we got this.
Are we gonna sell him?
I think so.
I don't know.
We might have to.
We could turn him if we don't have to.
31.
I mean...
Maybe we could spare him.
No, we care.
Airhorn has a higher value than Freddy Fazbear.
Freddy Fazbear's worth nothing.
Did Freeman cost more than Freddy?
Yeah, I think so.
I...
I don't know.
But, well, we can check.
Okay.
Save him for last, I guess, maybe.
I never actually got to see...
Yeah, yeah.
What's this?
Okay.
Oh, we don't have a cat anymore.
Oh.
Oh, everything's gone.
Aww.
Oh, my wonderful art.
It's up for you.
Okay, maybe...
Is that all?
Oh, I forgot the egg.
Okay.
Oh, watch out!
Watch out!
Oh, he didn't come out.
He's hungry!
He'll come, he's gonna come.
That was close.
That was...
Oh, we made quota!
We're good.
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
Yeah.
Maybe this is enough.
Did you hit it?
Please.
Feast.
Feast, my child.
Fish.
He's nervous.
There we go.
One swipe.
Hi there.
Oh, 141.
Nice.
Oh, the bells.
I think we're pretty rich.
We are.
Yeah.
We can.
Oh, we left the rubber ducky here.
It's okay.
He's good.
Yeah, he could stay there.
You're so pretty.
Oh, you're gonna buy flashlight?
Yeah, because I'm a chicken.
Ooh, he's sold.
I'm a chicken.
Oh, how do I quit terminal?
Okay, there we go.
Okay, you guys can use it now.
Oh!
How much we got?
I think we got 400.
400!
Hey, how many flashlights did you buy?
I only bought one.
Oh, I should have bought for everyone.
It's okay.
I don't use them, so...
I don't use the flashlights.
I'm sorry.
I'll buy one.
I'll buy a profile.
I'm gonna get it.
It's mine.
Oh, there you go.
How do I use this?
There you go.
Am I bright?
Yeah.
I can see your iPad.
Do you have an iPad?
I have an iPad!
Yeah, you do!
Enter.
I like your bunny ears.
Oh, you have bunny ears?
Yeah, you do.
Oh.
Nice.
Cool.
Oh, there's one more.
Chombo!
Oh, she have a, yeah, we need like...
Weapon.
I don't have a weapon.
Chombo!
Maybe the weapon.
Um, um, a shovel.
40% off.
Ooh, nice.
Did you guys get the flashlight?
There should have been two, I think.
A what?
It should have been two flashlights.
Guys, grab them or...
Because I couldn't find the other one.
I got mine, the one I ordered.
Let me go check.
I didn't see it.
Where's all?
I bought an extra shovel.
But it already is.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Watch out, watch out.
There it is.
Wow.
Logically.
Order one more.
No!
One more.
Wait!
What happened?
I couldn't knock the door.
It should have came in the thing.
With what?
Loud horn.
A hundred.
Translator?
What do you need a translator for?
You can talk to Goku.
we need the translator do you find a flashlight Emily should
I buy one yeah yeah I'll buy one more oh oh wait I'm waiting
for one more waiting for one Oh my, there's another...
Okay.
Wow, that's a delivery thing.
Did you catch another shovel?
Oh, is that much more?
We are shoveled.
How long did you have it in there for?
What's a flash?
For a long time.
I'm the yippee bug now.
I'm the yippee.
Yippee!
You took my loot.
Oh!
Did you- Oh!
You can kill, you can kill, and then you can feed to the
demon.
You could.
Where are we heading?
Wait, we can kill any more.
Oh.
We're going.
Where are we heading?
Moons?
Where are the murder?
Um...
Break this ship.
What is...
Oh, there's Dine.
Can we go there?
I don't know, Zala is...
I don't know what the numbers mean.
He's in one company anymore.
She's losing it.
She's on her stride.
She's on, oh my god!
Restrain her, restrain her!
Oh my gosh, you hurt me!
I'm sorry.
You need to get a, this is a team playing game.
It's okay.
You need to get yourself together.
I'll take it.
We need to work as a team.
Oh, sorry.
I'll stay out of the ship.
Wait, what happens if you guys fly and I stay out of the
ship?
This is why company needs to provide...
I think we actually...
No, I think it's...
I think you come back in.
True.
Oh, really?
Let's see.
We can check.
Can we go to Dine?
Dine?
Oh, it's 600.
Just kidding.
There we go.
What's Vow?
I'm on top of the world.
Oh, okay.
We're going to Vow.
Okay.
Woo!
Oh, never mind!
We have to start the ship.
Oh, okay, okay.
Nice.
Yushika!
I'm outside!
I can see the ship fly!
Where are you?
Aya-sama!
Come on.
Oh, I'm back.
Oh, okay, okay.
I thought I could see the ship fly from outside, but...
You can if you jump off it entirely, I think.
Oh!
We got overtime bonus now.
Yippee!
We got overtime bonus.
Okay.
Moons.
No problem.
Here we go.
It's good to land.
La la la la.
La na na na.
La la la.
I love when she starts singing.
Oh, I need a couple seconds.
Oh, yeah.
There's a moon with a mansion.
That might be fun.
Yeah, I want to go there, but we have to pay a lot of money
for it.
Oh, there's a big pumpkin.
Is this a pumpkin?
Oh, is this a pumpkin?
Smash the pumpkins.
Oh, oh, so.
I didn't know you like pumpkins that much.
I also like pumpkins.
Pumpkins are pretty good.
Not that much, yeah.
Freddy.
Hey, what?
I'm counting on you for dinner.
Yeah.
Where is it?
I think it's this way.
Oh,
yeah.
There's a beehive.
Ah!
Watch out!
Hello!
Come on over the water.
They're ready to bong.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
What's that guy doing?
He's just spinning.
That's what he said.
Let's go!
Okay, we in.
We're in.
Oh, I see something over here.
Oh, I got tea kettle.
Oh, I can't go.
Oh, there's a big room.
Is that something?
Oh, it's a remover.
Wait, it's a...
Oh, that can control things, actually.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Like,
like, farm one?
Yeah, hold on.
Watch.
Should I stand by this?
Was that the...
No, never mind.
That was the Whoopi Cushion.
I thought it was a sound of a mine.
Oh, a chemical.
Jugg.
Nice.
It's so big, though.
I know.
It's not in here.
No, I don't think so.
There was like a way down here though.
There's also a fire escape here.
Oh, that's a fire exit, but I'm not sure I trust in it.
Do we have that mod?
It's not like a fire exit in it.
I can't...
Maybe it's safe.
Alright.
I'm not sure I trust in it.
I don't think so.
We're fine.
We know how to get out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What's this way?
That's...
Nothing.
That's a dead end.
Oh, there's a way down.
Yeah.
It's the real down, right?
Okay.
I'm gonna put my stuff outside real quick.
Yeah, I heard something too.
Put it.
Actually, I'm gonna bring the whoopee cushion.
Oh, Yippie, you can kill it!
Okay, okay.
Kill it with the thing!
Wait, where are they?
Oh, how did you guys come down?
I feel like they're over there.
Are they there?
Where are you guys?
Guys?
Oh!
Yippie, can we hit it with a shovel?
Oh, they're over here!
Yeah, you can hit it.
Yeah, you can hit it, yeah.
Yeah, kill it with the shovel!
Hello!
Hi!
Yippie!
Fuck it, fuck it.
Kill it!
Yeah!
Ow!
Wait, wait, wait.
I think it's dead.
He's dead.
We got him.
Boy, we got him.
Idiot, hippie bud.
He's all toxic.
Is there anything else in here?
Can we take it home?
No, salute.
I don't think so.
There is a mine over here.
Yeah, there's a mine.
Watch out.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
It's like right there.
Watch out.
Just don't step on it.
Let's not step on it.
It's okay.
You got it.
Um.
Ta-da!
Okay.
Can we get this way?
Oh, there's another door.
Hi!
Oh, hi!
You can go this way.
Is that okay?
Oh, I found something.
Oh, a key!
I got it.
Nice.
Oh, there's something in here.
There's a magnifying glass!
Magnifying glass!
Let's go!
We left a lot of stuff at the entrance too, so...
Yeah, yeah, same.
Okay.
Nice.
I found a good amount.
I can't tell, I can't see anything.
Oh, it's okay, not right.
Yeah, follow, I'll lead the way.
I hear them laughing.
Oh, this way?
I think.
Hello?
Um, I think there's something over there.
What?
Which way?
Oh, this way.
Okay, over there.
Give me a piece.
Oh.
Where's the spot?
Oh, um.
Hello there.
What do we do?
I think you can kill it also, right?
Yeah, you can kill it.
Is that gonna be on the railing and kill it?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jump on the railing and kill it.
Oh, okay, okay, 50K.
It's yelling, it's using our voices.
Is your set and done, Dola?
No, we can do it, come here, come here.
You got this.
Okay.
I
think it might be lurking, but it might be gone.
Okay, yeah, let's go out.
Let's leave, let's leave, let's leave.
Let's pick them up.
Can you grab their stuff?
Yeah.
Can you?
Okay.
Ah, go, go, go, go, go.
Your pants are full?
Yeah, with Ayla Samo.
My hands are full.
Oh, your hands are full.
Wait, what's the most expensive thing here?
Do you think we can make it two times?
This one's full.
Okay, do you want to leave Ayla Samo?
Yeah, sorry, Ayla Samo.
And we'll come back for her.
Because money is pretty important too.
She's important, but money is like way important.
Yeah, but money.
Yeah, the money.
Okay, let's go.
All right.
We'll come back.
Oh, here.
I'll take the stone bridge.
You take that one.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
So far.
So good.
Okay.
Do we go back?
Oh, nice weapon cushion.
No, I don't know.
The one Pikachu was only 14!
Okay, how about I go grab the other stuff and you wait here?
No, no.
I'll go.
Are you sure?
Okay.
Hold on.
To a lot of responsibility.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
Wait, where is it?
What do you mean sorry?
What do you mean...
Min, min, min, I got it.
I got it.
Okay, okay.
I'll see you all.
On second thought, the giant is right there.
Actually, I think I can go.
I think I can go.
You can do it.
Hi, babe.
I think
we're in trouble.
I will kill myself before you could kill me, bitch!
You can't kill me!
I won't let you have the satisfaction Yeah Yeah try Come in
here Can you swim?
I don't think you can I won't let you have the satisfaction
Oh Oh I'm still alive I can make it I can make it I can make
it I can make it I can make it
Oh no!
No!
Emory, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh no,
I have no stamina left.
Emory, Emory, it's time to go.
I like it where you go.
I think Emory is still waiting for you.
Emory, it's time to go.
I mean, stop me.
go she's just sitting there menacingly
it's okay the ship is leaving automatically anyway oh she
doesn't know what time it is it says the ship is leaving in
one hour i think uh yeah come on just just go just go i'm
ready i think i'm gonna go oh there it is yeah it's gonna be
okay okay
something got her Yeah, something got me, all right.
It's all because I twerked at her.
Oh my god.
Ayla Sama is everything.
D for deceased.
Welcome back.
I feel like I'm very consistent with being the most paranoid
employee.
Oh.
No, that means you're just careful.
Dang, we lost so much stuff.
Oh, flashlight.
Yeah.
Yeah, the shovel.
There's one shovel here.
I brought back one.
I think there's also lions here.
Oh, nice.
You have like 163 in the ship, I think.
Uh-oh.
Wait, but we have two days.
We're good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right, everybody.
Yeah, good job, everyone.
One more flashlight.
163.
Good job.
I'm sorry towards you.
It's okay.
Oh, the flashlight is on sale in the walkie-talkie.
Wait, what got you?
Well, a titan saw me, or the giant saw me, and I didn't want
to give him the satisfaction, so I jumped into the water.
Ah.
Yeah.
That's a gamer movie.
The flashlight is on sale.
It's only $6.
Oh, $6.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
It's cheap, yeah.
It's cheap.
I don't need it, so you guys can have it there.
You could grab like two maybe I don't use one either.
So yeah, okay me and me and I level hold one.
How about that?
Good play.
Wait, I have my never mind.
I forgot I still have mine.
I didn't die.
So you don't need to.
Oh, sorry We just have extra in that case You have to get
shovels.
I'm not sure you have money even Wow, that was intense
Um...
Um, everything looks good.
Where haven't we gone?
Assurance?
Have we gone?
Or...
Oh, we've been there.
Oh, March?
I don't think we've gone to March.
Oh, yeah, we haven't.
Okay, let's go to March.
Yeah, let's go there.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Are we ready?
Oh, the farm is diverse.
Here we go.
What could it mean?
Diverse I have a lot to see.
I'm ready to kill.
I'm ready.
Once I make my move, you're free to check the king.
You think you could get the spider this time?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, actually, I don't know where it is, though.
On this map.
That spider was...
Oh, wait, it's this way.
I can see it.
Oh.
Wait, come up!
Watch out!
Don't fall in!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Be careful!
You will not make it if you fall in.
Yeah.
You will pass away probably.
Maybe.
Sport advisor.
Yeah.
Let's go!
Weehoo!
Oh, Luigi.
Did I hear that?
Oh!
Wait, did someone hear that?
Go get it, go get it!
Go get it!
There's a large axle.
Wait, if someone...
Wait, wait, wait.
Where's the axle?
Uh, right here.
Try picking it up and then dropping it.
And dropping it?
Oh my god, oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Yeah!
Oh, hello!
I got jump scare.
So good.
Nice.
I can hear it?
I can hear it from inside.
Oh, is that loud?
Yeah.
Did you miss the flashlight?
I missed it.
What?
You missed it?
There's nothing in here.
Oh no!
At least it was on sale.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay.
Yeah.
This is the only way we can go.
That's gonna- Down kind of disappear.
Down is the only way- Watch out, there's a mine down here
though.
Okay, okay.
Be careful.
Oh.
Oh, oh, okay.
What is it?
On the floor?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, on the floor.
Oh, there's a- There's a- there's a- Oh, a clown- Oh, clown
horn?
Did you find something?
Oh!
It's me.
I found my accessory.
Oh!
It looked like a flash.
A little bit.
Oh, it's right here.
Oh, where's everyone?
And then?
Over here!
Oh!
Hello!
You were camouflaging.
Oh, I am.
It's gonna be suit.
Sorry.
I know, I'm so sneaky.
Haha.
Oh, there's one more.
It's so dark.
It is really dark.
This is dead end?
What was that?
I'm trying to conserve the battery.
Oh, there's a door here.
There's a door here.
I heard something.
There's a door over here.
Oh, nice.
There's one more here And Leads into here Oh there's another
axle Oh let's go Oh someone should hold it Oh sorry Someone
else should hold that so I can have the flash I got it I got
it Alright There's some more down
So good So good Wait Sorry Sorry Where is he?
Where is he?
Oh no!
What's that?
You guys, it's a spring, it's a spring back.
It's a coil head!
It's a coil head.
Come on, come on, come on.
It follows you.
Really?
Come on, come on.
I'm like...
We out?
Yeah, yeah, you have to look it in.
Wait, is this the dog?
It's me, it's me, it's me, it's me.
All right.
Wait, you guys, I can't turn around.
Where are you?
Johnny!
Okay.
This way?
All right.
Come, come.
Turn around.
Yeah.
And then let's close the door.
Nice.
This is a dead end.
Watch out.
Can you go through the...
There's no way out here.
Wait.
Are we trapped?
Yeah, we're trapped.
Yeah, this is a dead end.
Why did you guys hide in here?
Would you guys lead us to a den?
We can get around him, we can get around him.
Yeah?
I think.
Hello.
I'm looking at him.
You guys are good.
I'm looking, I'm looking, I'm looking.
Okay, okay...
No.
No, this is a dead end.
Okay.
Look at him, still.
Look at him?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're going, we're going, we're going.
But I can't see it.
I can't see anything.
Okay.
It's a dead one.
I think we're going to die.
We're going to die.
Really?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Back here, back here.
Where's this lady?
What do you need to?
Oh, he's right there, he's right there.
Yeah,
stop pushing me!
Stop pushing!
Uh-oh.
Who am I hearing?
Okay, where are we going?
Hey, where are we going?
I think we're There's a thought for...
Um, let's go here.
Here, here, here.
There's a door here.
Okay.
I don't know where it's here.
Try.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Where's Goku?
Yeah, why do we keep getting these guys?
Oh shoot, it's a dead end!
Yeah, I think that's the same door we went through before.
Oh my god.
What?
It looks like the dead end.
Yeah.
You can't go there.
Tall and handsome.
Where do we go?
Where is it?
Oh my god.
Uh...
No, this one's the one with the theme.
Watch yourself as well.
Sayonara!
Wait, the thumper totally ignored me.
Oh, never mind.
Sayonara!
I'm gonna leave it, I'm gonna leave it.
I don't wanna be alone.
Oh, there's a dead end.
Oh, shoot.
Is everybody dead?
I'm lost!
This is the dead end.
Oh.
Are you dead?
Ah!
Oh,
he's dead!
Oh, she got him!
Oh, he's still dead!
Oh my gosh.
She's so dead!
She's got the animal too.
Yeah, that was knocking.
Who's yelling?
Can you find a way out, Aya-sama?
When I died, I dropped the animal so I- Just the three of
you.
I just did.
I'll try to follow you.
Oh no, he's blocking the way.
Really?
Yeah, I can't get up.
I think you can touch him.
It's a dead end.
Wait, did it just repeat the axle sound?
I guess we're soft locked.
I think the other monster is like...
I might have.
The skinwalker.
Excuse me.
Oh wait, they actually can't move?
Oh no, I think he's actually blocking me.
Can I push him?
Push him away?
I think they have to not look and then...
Yeah, they might have to like run for it.
Maybe couch?
Ah!
Oh!
There it is, there it is, there it is, there it is!
Oh my god!
My
god, it's so funny.
I'm so paranoid.
I don't know.
I don't think it's properly...
I don't think it's working, yeah.
We lost everything.
Have any of us, like, seen a bracken?
Yeah, we've seen the bracken.
Oh, really?
But it didn't work?
No, it's okay.
Rip, rip, go cool.
They got him, they got him!
Oh, man.
We lost everything.
Wait, someone said Val has high Goku chance?
Really?
Should I believe you?
I'm gonna believe you.
Can we go there?
It's a Goku a chance?
It's foggy, though.
It's foggy.
Ah, it's gonna be hard.
We gotta pick risks.
You know, we're at zero money here.
You're right.
You're so right.
Here we go.
No pain, no gain.
No pain.
No gain.
Let's go, baby.
Yeah.
Goku in the fog.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh, yeah.
It's foggy.
Don't have any items, too.
Now we got nothing.
Oh, my shovel.
Wait, how do we get to the...
Where's the door?
Uh, we keep scanning, I guess.
Yeah.
Just keep scanning.
We'll find it.
Here we go.
I think it's this way, actually, right?
Yeah, this way.
Yeah, the bridge?
Maybe we have to find the bridge.
Yeah, I think it's this way.
It's just Emory.
I got jumpskin.
I know I'm very scary.
Oh yeah, right here.
Oh, there you go.
Nice!
With the concrete ones?
Yep.
Oh, nice.
Where's Naki?
Naki?
Naki!
You're lucky!
Uh oh.
She's not dead already.
There's no way.
Naki!
Maybe she's just left.
Should I really show you what?
I'm gonna go inside.
Okay.
And you guys, if you find her, bring her over.
Right there.
All right.
Actually, it's quite spooky being in here by myself.
What if it's the word Goku?
Oh, you made it!
Yeah!
They're looking- Yeah, they're looking for you outside.
Here, let's go tell them.
It's okay, it's you in half!
Hi, Naki's inside!
I found a way!
Is that you?
Yeah.
Is that you, Naki?
Oh my god, Emory went to look for you!
Sorry, I was lost, yeah.
Oh my god, Emory went to look for you.
Okay, Emory will come back, it's fine.
Yeah, yeah.
Now we gotta find Emily.
Emily!
How did she navigate in this fog?
It's so hard.
You should have just left me.
How did you get that?
Emily!
Yeah, I got this.
But...
Emily!
I'm gonna go back in.
I
don't know why Emily might be lost.
Yeah, maybe.
Money over friendship.
Nothing.
Goku.
Did you sacrifice myself?
Yeah.
Boy, you can find something.
Yeah, we gotta find a little bit.
Go.
Yay!
Oh, everyone's here!
Yippee!
I almost got lost again.
How do you guys find me?
It's that far.
Oh, it's another freaking name.
Yeah, I hate these ones.
Oh, there's something.
There's something.
Oh, no, he's okay.
He's okay.
Oh, he's okay?
Yeah.
He'll leave you, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just don't get too close to him, you know.
He wants personal space, I guess.
Yeah, actually, I don't know where he is, though.
That's too dark.
Oh, and here is a big room.
Oh, there's a lot in here.
Oh, dude!
Wow.
Nice.
My hands are cool.
Oh, do you want me to carry something?
I can carry.
I'm good.
Oh, there's a staircase over here, too.
Oh, I'm going to go down.
Goku.
Goku What
the heck?
Oh really?
This voice was that?
Not only one, but two.
Wow.
That's steel.
Nice.
Mm-hmm.
Double.
Okay, I got hairbrushes.
I didn't fully inspect this room yet.
Is there anything else?
Oh yeah.
Let's check up this room.
Oh there is?
Oh yeah.
Oh there's more.
Here I'll check up.
Yeah, I don't like the sound of that though.
Yeah.
Is it the fog, the steam?
Oh no, it's just this thing.
It's just the power.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I can't flip the switch.
I can't see any.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, there's a lot of stuff down here.
There's a lot of stuff down here.
Yeah, it seems like it.
Oh, oh, sorry.
Oh, right here.
I'm a liar.
I can hold stuff.
There's nothing here.
Oh, there's nothing here.
It just looks like it.
It gasped, you know.
It really, I thought that.
I thought this shadow was something.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's Lee, you.
Goku, Goku.
I think she's being really adventurous.
Oh!
He's here again!
It's okay.
Uh-oh.
We gotta go back.
Bye.
Have any of us, like, seen a bracken?
Bye!
Oh, wait!
Where is it?
I'm looking at him!
Oh god.
Oh.
Do we go down or over here?
Down?
I'm looking.
Yeah, the stairs over here.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, I'm up.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, yeah, that's right.
That's right, that's right, that's right.
Oh, man.
Okay.
You're looking at him, I'm looking at him.
You're looking?
Okay, uh, okay.
It's, uh, it's right over here.
It's over here.
Oh, I think.
I think it's this one.
There's another door over here.
Oh, wait, I don't know which one it is then.
Hey!
I'm looking!
You cheater!
You are cheater!
I'm looking at you!
You can't do that!
There's a door over here!
Which door is it?
Which one is it?
Here, over here!
Oh, okay.
Okay, let's go this way.
The egg, sleep.
I'm looking at him.
I'm looking at you!
Yeah, he's a big old cheater.
Mm-hmm.
Ah!
Oh my god.
No!
Oh, it's fine.
We were dead anyway.
Yeah, it's okay.
Oh boy.
Do we wanna just go to another moon instead?
We're getting tired.
Yeah, maybe a more challenging moon for higher value?
I don't think, well, we're gonna die.
We don't have enough money to do a challenging moon.
Yeah, true.
We're broke.
Yeah, wait, what's Rend?
Yeah.
Um...
The way we all died there.
So funny.
Wait, Naki, how did you die?
Ooh!
You're going to so fancy, man.
There's no coil head there.
Oh wait, you died?
You died to the coil head?
Not as well.
Oh no.
I got separated and I was the one who met him.
But, um, couldn't get through him.
I don't even get...
What's M bringing?
Wow, so purple.
There's a free moons mod?
Really?
Free moons.
There's apparently a free moons mod.
Oh.
I didn't know that.
I didn't know that either.
Where should...
You know what?
Let's just go to experimentation.
Okay.
There was also a gambling mod I hesitated on adding.
Wait, what's that?
What?
You can like, on the last day, you can like take all your
items and if it's not enough, you could like try a hand at
gambling to see if you can make them worth more or something
or if you can earn more.
Yeah, that's cool.
All right, are we going?
Yep, let's just go.
We're not gonna live, but we can at least explore.
Oh, it says we have to go to the company.
What?
They changed it!
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, let me see.
Let me try it one more time.
We can hold it, I think.
Oh yeah, I just need to hold it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, just hold it.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
Nice.
We're not following your rules, company!
Yeah.
Yeah, company sucks.
Yeah, we're dead anyway.
We're dead men walking.
Woohoo!
It is so purple.
We're rebelling.
Yeah, we're rebelling.
Yeah.
Pumpkins.
Overthrow the company.
It's over there.
Now I don't go to the mansion, but it costs a lot.
It does cost a lot.
I'm going to go through the fire escape here.
Okay.
I think it's this way, yeah.
Yeah, it's up this.
Up the stairs!
I'm coming in!
Oh!
Hello?
Oh, there we go!
Oh my god.
Oh shoot, it's locked!
We can't go out.
There's a wedding ring!
I can grab it!
A wedding ring!
I guess we gotta leave though.
Wow, that must be worth a lot.
I think it was like 80 something.
Oh my god.
The engagement ring is very expensive.
I will choose who to marry whoever gathers the most items.
It is a battle of survivors.
She wants to marry to money for the purchase.
No, no, no.
It's- it's not money.
It's not the money.
It's the- Infinite money.
It's the- Oh.
It's your sense of adventure.
Come on.
I'll follow that.
Oh!
Oh, that scared me.
What was that?
I have that already.
It was just a door.
Oh, there's a gift box!
Oh, there's a gift!
There's a gift box!
Gotcha!
Here.
There you go, Emily.
Yay!
I did the last one.
How do you open it?
Just left click, I think.
Yeah, you guys ready?
Yeah.
It's so good!
Yeah, the radiation's been here.
Oh my gosh.
It's okay.
A little radiation won't hurt.
Oh, there's another one.
There's one more.
What, really?
Oh, there's another door over here.
Oh my gosh, there's so many of them.
Yeah.
Wait, this is the same area, right?
Oh, this is the same.
Yeah, we just went in a circle.
Oh yeah, we just went around.
Wait, which way was it?
This way?
Yeah.
Follow me?
That way?
Follow me.
Did we go down?
No?
I think so.
Okay.
Oh, there's nothing here.
Nothing here.
One, one, one.
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, we've got...
Lost.
What if we all drop it at the same time?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You want to try?
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Count down, yeah.
Okay.
Uh, three, uh, two, uh, one.
Oh.
Got it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Okay.
Bring it home.
Let's go.
Oh, shoot.
There's a bee?
No, those are good.
Those are fine.
I think those are fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, it should be fine.
Yeah, the bees only gather around the harmful bees gather
around the hive.
Oh.
Yeah.
Alright.
Wow.
Ash and Middok is here.
Let's go see if we can find Goku.
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna find Goku.
Goku, where?
Goku, where is he?
Actually, that's what this wedding ring is for.
It's for him.
Oh, it's dark.
I know you're afraid of commitment!
I know you have chichi, but what about Mimi?
I don't think that's Goku.
Where is him up?
I can't say I.
Oh.
Oh, hello?
Hi.
There's a thumper.
Oh, okay.
Oh, there she is.
Yeah.
I don't think we can go over there.
Um, why?
Um.
Um, um, I think, yeah.
Yeah, I think we should...
That was a close one.
It's...
He's probably gone.
Did you want to, like, propose to the author?
I was trying to find Goku.
Oh, Goku, Goku, sir.
Yeah.
The man in marriage.
It wasn't Goku?
No.
Yeah.
And the fabled Goku.
What?
I think I let it.
Oh my gosh.
The thumper's in the way.
Yeah, we can't go any further.
Man.
I thought you guys were going to die.
Can't believe he's blockiest from Goku.
You know what?
I'm, you know what?
I, this guy is a jerk.
I'm going to go teach him a lesson.
I.
Hey, you.
Hey, get out of here.
This is our...
Oh, I'm okay.
Yeah?
Yeah, I'm actually...
I'm actually okay.
I don't know where I am though.
You
good?
Where are you?
Oh.
No, everybody I'm hearing...
Oh god.
I was hearing more voice.
I was hearing the everybody from the dead.
That was not Goku.
That's just a disappointment.
It's not Goku at all.
It's just sad.
You're an imposter?
Are you the real Ayla Sama?
Yes.
You can quiz me.
Only the real Ayla Sama would know the right answers.
Right.
Ayla Sama cute.
Oh, wow.
Hello.
No, that's the imposter.
That's the imposter.
Me?
No, no, no.
It's her.
It's her because she said oh, I'm gonna teach this monster a
lesson and then she died I didn't die everybody died Oh my
god, I saw my sus sus me sus Sus I think that's the wrong
Sus I'm not sus I'm not sus you're sus You know what?
I'm gonna walk off this ship.
I hear something.
You did this!
Oh my god.
Oh.
Because she's the imposter, do you mean?
Yeah.
I am the imposter.
I'm gonna take us all down.
Where?
No!
I'm gonna...
Oh,
uh-oh.
You're not gonna leave without me, right, guy?
That'd be crazy.
All right.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I can't open it.
I thought you were gonna go.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I...
All right.
You gotta shake it.
You think Emily is gonna come back anytime soon?
Or...
Oh, she's dead.
I saw it.
I think we should leave.
I'm gonna teach this guy a lesson.
What is happening?
Hello, welcome to the dead.
Hello, I've been here the whole time.
Oh my gosh, they didn't believe you that I died.
They left.
And now we're all gonna die together.
You are paranoid!
You're gaslighting us!
I can't really lie so blatantly.
We owe a dollar.
We owe one money.
Here we go.
Time to die!
Let's die!
They can't catch me over here.
You should use the wedding ring!
Use the ring!
One money.
One single money.
Oh, seven, everybody.
The maid brigade?
I'm fired.
Hello.
Oh, we're back to our normal suit.
Yay!
I mean, I am changing.
Boo, yeah.
Vigi.
Big bush.
Well, I feel like I've met you guys before.
Is it deja vu?
Deja vu.
Oh, yeah.
Maybe Mario.
I've never met you guys before.
Mama Mia.
Brother.
I've never met you before in my life, except you, my
brother.
She didn't remember us.
She's so sad.
You should know her, but you're both Nintendo.
Yeah, I was going to say, you look pretty familiar.
Are you the real, are you my real brother?
Oh!
Can't believe it's a real Mario!
It's a long-lost reunion!
Not gonna lie, I thought you were my princess Peach.
Mmmmm-mm-mm-mm-mm-mm-mm.
Oh, happy to be you.
Cheers!
Yes, yes!
I mean, I mean, Wario.
I mean, Wario.
I thought you were Wario.
I thought Wario!
I've become such a Rizzler.
My God, it is sauce.
Red is sauce, yeah.
Yeah, red is sus, red is sus.
No, this is, I'm Mario with a...
Oh, brother, I think you changed a little.
Yeah, I've changed.
I'm Mario from actual New York.
I'm from Mario.
Brooklyn.
So Brooklyn, does you?
Yeah, that's been a hard life.
Mario with attitude.
Let's see.
You guys want to try to get the mansion?
Yeah, let's play, like, serious, and we'll try to get the
mansion.
Yeah, yeah, okay, okay, let's try to get the mansion.
I don't know what the numbers mean.
We've never been in here.
We can go to March, again, we can try.
Ooh.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Sorry, I confirmed.
Yeah, just audio glitches.
Let's do this.
Let's do this for real.
Oh, constant rain.
It's raining.
Oh, no, wait.
It didn't say it was raining.
It says constant rain.
Uh-oh.
Oh, there we go.
Still have to.
Oh, no.
Can we change it, right?
Can we change it?
The raining has lightning strike, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, I didn't say.
The numbers.
What do they mean?
Try.
There's Rend, Dine, and Titan.
Right.
Those are the ones that we can't afford.
Oh, we can't afford them.
Yeah, they're like.
like 600 what no it is maybe experimentation is pretty easy
yeah I think I think we'll go with the classic yeah okay oh
my gosh you turn off the lights okay oh someone said that's
just flavor text not the weather really so it's not actually
really oh really oh okay let's just go to it Yeah, that
might be just a description.
Can you tell the truth?
Are they gaslighting?
Oh, wait, are they gaslighting us?
I can't tell, actually!
I don't feel like I trust.
That's true.
Now to go to Luigi's Mansion!
We gotta go there eventually.
Yeah, we have to get money to go there.
Wahoo!
Okay.
Only if it says it on the list.
Yeah, but one time it didn't say Eclipse and it was actually
Eclipse.
Yeah, that's true.
We can try it.
We'll learn something now.
Oh, Luigi time.
Okay.
Here we go.
I'm a Luigi number one.
I think I like being Mario now.
I'm a Luigi.
Number one.
Number.
Oh, yeah, it is fine.
Yeah, yeah, it looks okay.
Yeah.
We made it!
Got something.
Got something immediately.
Yeah.
It's right there.
You know what?
I'm just gonna leave it outside.
There we go.
Run me.
It's really dark.
I'm with you.
Oh, okay.
I'm behind you.
Oh, that's a dead end.
Dead end.
Turn around.
What's that?
Oh, it's a me.
It's a me.
The leader.
Oh, it's a dead end.
Oh, mama mia.
Mama mia.
Oh.
I think I'm gonna get lost in here, brother.
Yeah.
Oh, there's another...
Yeah, there's a door over here.
What's that?
Oh, it's lit up.
Something glowing over there.
Oh, it's a...
Oh, there's a key.
There's a key.
I got an engine.
Got it?
Oh, not.
I can make this...
There's a key over there.
Don't, maybe.
I think you can.
I think you can do it, brother.
I believe in you.
Okay.
Mama Luigi, number one!
There's shit.
There should be a platform.
Oh, there we go.
It's over here.
Oh, there you go.
She did it.
Can you get to the door over there, too?
Yeah.
Is there anything in there?
It's the same maze.
Oh, it's another maze.
Yeah, it might be connected to the other room.
Do you want me to...
Well, it might be.
over there can you with that big thing yeah okay don't die
i'm a louisie number one yeah oh i do whatever everything my
brother cannot oh i i i'm sorry mario i i'm sorry mario
No!
All that cardboard for nothing, I guess we gotta go back.
Be careful!
Very good.
Wait, did we go here or there?
Uh, we haven't gone this way.
We can check it out.
What's that noise over here?
What does that sound?
Oh!
If we pass through there, it'll- Oh!
It's a trap!
trap yeah yeah retreat retreat retreat i thought you were
good at dodging traps mario i what i dodged the trap what
are you talking about i did that i did dodge here my brother
on the other hand poor poor fool my brother died i'm
scanning oh oh nice oh we made it all naki i think so Whoa!
She was gaming while we were...
Yeah!
We said we were gonna play for real.
What is that?
The...
Oh, it's just a thing.
A mantacle.
Ayla Sama!
How was she already?
How was she already dead?
I think we should just go home.
No?
I think they're dead.
They are dead.
I think we should just go.
We almost start the ship.
Yeah, I think we should just leave.
I think it's fine.
Does Emily fail a parkour?
Yeah, that's what happened.
Yeah, that's okay.
I'm ashamed to be the brother anymore.
I thought Luigi was supposed to be glad jumping.
It means your camera shakes the most when you're paranoid.
You're like, like shaking the camera.
Oh, really?
Yeah, I think so.
Big bro.
Where did a big bro go?
He abandoned me.
I'm big boss now.
I don't know.
He just acknowledged I'm the better brother.
I didn't want to be- I didn't want to be related to you any
longer.
I'm ashamed.
Wait, are you- are you knuckles?
Is that- are you knuckles?
I'm knuckles.
Oh my god, there is knuckles in here.
Yeah, yeah.
What does it look like?
She's wearing a mask.
What is Slayer?
What do I look like?
Oh, mom.
What is that?
It's like a green and black suit.
Yeah.
You have a mountain duo behind you.
Oh, I do?
I'm a gamer?
Yeah, you do.
Red mountain duo.
Now you have an eyeball.
Oh, banana.
Banana.
Well, I'm Doom guy?
I have a yellow sign.
I think it suits you.
The yellow?
Yeah, the yellow.
It's okay.
Now that Mario's gone, I'm the best brother.
It's all according to Luigi's plan.
Yeah.
Yes, of course.
of course yes I was I was the better brother all along let's
see um we can go to March again or experimentation do you
like that Isla summer do you like do you like that yeah so
if you if you like pay for a place if you pay for a place
you can you just keep pressing the button and you don't have
to pay for it any again until you die oh wow yeah wow all
right where are we going um we can just go to march again
okay since we're already here I won't
we're playing for real guys this is the real deal this is
the real real thing.
No death run.
Here we go.
This is the run.
Zero death speed run any person.
Exactly, exactly.
Hoi!
All right.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, watch out for the ho, ho, ho,
ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Yahoo!
Oh my god.
I can't, I have it in my blood.
I'm not Mario anymore, but I can't stop Yahoo!
It's in my genes.
It's in my DNA.
It's like Yahoo!
I want to keep saying Yahoo so the skin walker will say it.
Yahoo!
It's Yoshi.
Oh, nice!
Yoshi!
Wow!
Let's see what's down here.
I think it's a dead end.
Oh, no, never mind.
No, there's more.
Oh, there's a key.
Nice.
Oh, it's the light thing.
It's the apparatus.
Yeah.
Oh.
Money.
I can't grab this bottle.
What the heck?
I know.
Why is it...
Should I get the apparatus?
Oh, we can wait.
We can have the...
Yeah, it's too foreign.
Oh, it's just a loop, I think.
Wait.
This is where we came from, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think so.
I'm gonna leave this outside.
I'll come back.
Yep.
Did you hear me drop it from out there?
I didn't hear it.
I don't think it goes through the door.
Oh, there's a metal sheet.
I got it.
Where?
I got a sheet.
Which way did you go?
I went downstairs, but I think it's a dead end.
Oh, no, no, there's more.
There's more, there's more here.
There's more?
Okay.
Yeah, come on.
Brivar.
I want.
Yahoo!
Oh, there's another metal sheet.
Oh nice!
Yahoo!
I do have a key in case there's anything lost.
Oh, watch out, watch out.
I don't know.
I heard it.
I don't know where.
Where is it?
Also the fire that's here, we can leave.
Yeah, but where's the mine?
Maybe on a ceiling?
Can it be on a ceiling?
I don't know.
Where is it?
Oh god.
I was scared.
it seems so close it does it does where is it oh it might be
over here like in the corner do we have the fake fire exit
mod on no no no we don't we don't have it oh we don't have
it okay oh i got a thing too oh where is that hello oh hi oh
hi i said it would be funny if I said that, but it ended up
being the mod.
And we can go.
Wait.
I don't know how to get back.
I don't know how to get there from here.
We can figure it out.
Oh, behind.
Watch out.
Is it this way?
Oh, are you going straight?
Wait, which way?
Where'd you go?
I'm here.
I feel like if we go get the high ground, right, we can see.
Oh, true, true, true.
smart 10 side oh now i'm lost uh this way okay maybe oh
this way i feel like i just oh we just walked i think we
just walked wait watch out watch out
yeah i'm good it's safe it's safe I think we can go up here.
Like up here.
Okay, okay.
Wait, I...
Oh, that's the main entrance.
Oh, okay.
We're close then.
We can get from the main entrance.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
We're not lost.
Oh, there's a large axle that you got.
Oh, I can grab it.
I can grab it.
Okay, take me.
Go for it.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
Gaming, gaming.
Finally, I'm not there.
You're playing the game for real.
Yeah, I'm fine.
Okay.
And it's good.
It's still early.
Yeah, we should be fine.
We should be good.
I think Nucky and I live in there.
Where are you going?
I went the wrong way.
I'm okay.
I went the wrong turn.
Okay.
Nice.
I'll just forget about that.
Nice, guys.
Oh wow, we have a lot of money, yeah.
253.
No.
Another moon?
No, not the bigger ones, no.
I need more money.
Should we go back?
Let me check the camera.
Yeah, see how they're doing.
Yeah, yeah.
Uh, she's not moving.
What's the little green thing on?
Isn't that a loop?
What about Naki?
Oh, Naki's coming!
Naki's moving!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
But she's getting- I think the green thing's just where
they're facing.
Wait, I don't know.
Oh, I can't tell.
It's not moving though.
I think she's dead.
Naki's coming.
Oh.
Hmm.
Ehh.
I hear...
I hear her.
Oh!
Ay, Ay!
I think she was with me.
I think she fell.
Oh, she fell.
Oh!
She fell.
Oh, she fell.
Oh.
No, she's not moving?
No, she's not moving.
She's just kind...
Yeah, I think she fell.
Lazy!
Lazy employee!
What are you doing?
Paranoid and lazy.
Whombo combo.
Ayla Sama, if you can hear this, this one's for you.
You heard us?
It sounds like a...
It sounds like an elephant or something.
No.
I'm Kai.
Oh, we're worried herself.
She died.
I guess we can go then.
Are we good?
Yeah.
Yeah, we got a lot.
We can go.
It's 5 p.m.
I think we should go.
Yeah, okay.
Go.
Let's go.
With my Ilosama.
Hello, Ilosama.
She was with me.
Wait a minute.
She's still with us in spirit.
It's true.
She's probably hearing our voices now and watching the song
above.
Yeah, Ilosama.
already an angel.
I'm
lazy.
I'm careless.
I got her two eggs.
Two Easter eggs.
That's a huge...
That's big.
That is actually big.
I just dropped it.
Oh, she's on an Easter egg hunt.
But it's not Easter anymore.
Look at my bunny ears.
Yeah.
Where are we gonna go?
First stop sign.
Yeah, what are we gonna do with this?
Um...
We can go to...
Offense?
Whoops, I'm sorry.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hey, hey.
This is a professional environment, everybody.
Stop, stop.
I'm...
Yield.
I'm not doing anything.
Let's go to...
I'm on my best behavior.
And I'm... Wait, what is this?
Confirm.
B.
For the big boss.
Yeah, big.
Yeah.
Oh, that's for me.
Is that, is this for me also?
Yeah, that's for you.
For you.
What happened?
Wait, I can't salute back at you.
Wait, can I twerk at you?
Whoa, what was that?
Oh, why is, why is the bed in the middle of the...
Oh, what's going on?
I'm telling us how.
You guys are rearranging the...
Oh, it's lovely.
I like the decor.
Yeah.
Oh, we can't get out.
Wait.
We gotta rearrange though.
We're stuck.
How do we...
Move it.
I'll move it.
We can go around.
Oh, no, no.
It's B.
Because B and you move it.
Wait, I can't move it.
I can't move it.
Oh, sorry.
Ah, that's so good.
Did you hit me?
No, that wasn't me.
I don't know if anything you quit.
What was that?
How are we moving?
It wasn't me.
I'm innocent.
Stop, son.
Collected.
Is it this way?
Actually, I have no idea where I'm going.
I wonder who.
They said press B.
And I did.
Is it this way?
I actually have no idea where I'm going, you guys.
Shaggy.
Rugggy.
Wait, can I jump over here?
Oh, no.
Nice.
And now I'm stuck.
Oh, wait.
What?
What is this?
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
I think I'm a genius.
Bro, bro.
Where's the Scooby-Doo mod?
Doesn't that mean something's close?
This music?
Right?
I'm not crazy, right?
Yeah, because now...
Now I can't hear it.
Big bolt.
Where?
Oh, oh, mine.
Mine, okay.
Hello?
Whoa?
Okay.
Oh, it's over there.
Oh, wait, someone.
Stop talking.
Are you real?
You scared me.
There's a key back here.
There's a key back here, but don't stop on the mine.
Oh!
Oh, there's mine.
Yeah.
You locked through.
You locked through your phone.
Oh, careful.
I'm going to go drop this.
Nothing else here.
Oh, I got a robot.
There's a robot.
Nice.
Okay, I'm going to try.
You guys don't hear music?
It's like an ambiance, you know?
It's not like a music.
It's like a...
I have no excuse.
It's going crazy.
I'll leave you outside.
I have no excuse except...
um that um i overcompensated actually getting loot i
overcompensated there's a whole space down there there's a
way in a bad way there's a whole area down there oh yeah i'm
gonna go back and drop myself i like if you die when you're
um all right oh wow robot if you die when you're um what's
the word crouch do you get the snark
It's okay.
Which one?
Wait, did they get those?
Oh, oh shoot!
Oh shoot!
I just heard something.
Oh no!
The bones?
Kill it!
Hit him!
Oh nice.
Yeah, yeah.
Hello.
I saved your life.
Oh, I lost the sign.
Oh my god.
Oh sure, thank you for the 50 gift.
Thank you so much.
Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
How are you guys doing today?
I haven't been able to talk to you so much because of the
collab.
Man, that is not the right way to go.
Oh my gosh, it killed me!
She's crazy!
She's lost all control!
She truly lost it!
I just wanted to give her a little ball.
I'm dead and she's laughing!
I was so sorry You're not sorry What the fuck I told her I
was no one HP I'm sorry I'll only grab your body Yeah, you
better Oh, I can't I mean, you can't You can't Oh, she is so
scary I will not add I don't know the way back.
She's going the wrong way.
Yep, that way.
Good job.
That way, that way.
Good job, good job.
Yeah.
I'm not laughing, though.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, the dogs are already out.
Oh, maybe her unrivaled wood.
Oh, yeah, okay.
Um...
Wait, why is it...
I should go back, I'm running.
I'm not sure she could fly her way.
Yeah, I don't know.
all if she can.
There we go.
No, no, this is the main entrance!
She's so lost!
Dummy, Dummy, Dummy, Dummy!
Oh, Alyssa, you're so dumb.
She's unravelling!
I know not.
Just watch.
Of course I'm watching!
I'm watching you!
I'm just going around!
Be careful.
Oh.
She killed you good.
No, I died to a bug.
Oh my god, Naki's hand just crouch, just crouch.
They won't see you if you crouch.
The weight of her studentism.
I think she's gonna die.
I wonder if Mince and Emory is dead.
I hope not.
Oh, stop.
You're the one that killed people!
I brought this upon myself.
Is this a ship?
Yeah!
Crouch, crouch, crouch.
I thought my yoke, crouch!
Okay,
this is her chance to go though, but she's not crouching,
she won't crouch.
This is...
The corpse is all on you now.
If you can hear their voices, what the fuck?
You can hear us?
Crouch!
If you can hear us, crouch!
Go!
No!
Not the run.
This is not the ride.
Why are you doing?
Why are you doing this?
Oh, there's no...
Oh, you're sorry.
Yes!
No!
I don't want to leave you there.
Sorry, there's a sign that's moving.
They were everywhere.
My head's so sad.
Pain.
I owe Naki an apology.
I'm sorry, Naki.
She killed me!
I told you I was low on HP!
I just wanted you to help me and go and grab it.
You help me die, I guess.
What do we do?
Just feeling still.
Oh, this stuff is gone.
Sorry, guys.
Rip.
I'm so sad.
I would never trust you again.
I love how I'm trust for you.
Wait, so what happened between you guys?
Elisaba killed me!
What?
She hit me!
Actually!
I can explain.
No, you don't need to explain.
Look at my gesture right now.
Aw, she's just a minion.
She's just a minion.
I'm such a minion He started to kill her Yeah No no no no no
Okay what happened was we both escaped Okay And then she
left her sign And I was like Oh Naki you're so silly And
then I bonked her head I bonked her head Just a little silly
Just a love bonked Those signs were powerful Oh my god I
thought I wouldn't kill you I need a bonk you know It was
the vlog.
I was low in HP, so I didn't want to go back in there.
I saw my did the finishing touch, you know.
See, because you're losing.
You guys threw me and you're close to the ship, so I thought
you'd make it back, so I didn't, like, I didn't, like, start
the ship.
Yeah.
But no, you...
What happened, though, with you was so messed up.
That was...
That shouldn't have happened.
Wait, wait.
I should have not died.
Because I was...
Okay, I was crouching the entire time here.
Oh.
Yeah, and then the dog was clipping through the ship.
Yeah, and then it ate her.
Yeah, like, I don't even understand.
I was safe, man.
Little whoopsie.
It's okay.
Let's just, let's just, uh, we can just, like, land and then
take back off and die.
Oh, my God.
I haven't, I haven't seen the knuckle's face until now.
Do you know the way?
Are you looking?
My face.
I don't know!
I don't know, it looks like a very nerdy novel.
Can you do the thing?
Bang it.
I don't know.
She doesn't know the way!
She doesn't...
She doesn't know the way, Daniel?
She doesn't know the way?
Oh, you can't write a Jackson console?
Oh, I don't know.
No way!
Honestly, that means I would not respond.
I'm not responding to any requests from you.
You guys want to like die or do you want to like yeah, I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna die.
I'm just gonna die Okay, yeah, let's yeah, there we go.
Let's just accept it.
Yeah, basically.
It's gone.
It's like a lost run
I'm going to bye
They spared you
You don't think that the dogs heard the Metal Gear music,
right?
Oh, did they?
I don't think so, right?
I don't have no idea.
I would talk if that was the case.
Sayonara!
We are back.
This is the run, everybody.
Maybe doing good.
Are you guys feeling okay?
Wait, why did I turn?
You guys feeling good?
Yeah!
I'm gonna do it though as long as someone is like, you know,
taking away from me.
I'm sorry, okay?
I'm sorry!
Trust has been lost.
I'm scared of you.
I'm scared.
I'm traumatized.
I'm gonna do therapy session.
Don't worry, I will redeem myself.
I will redeem myself.
I believe you.
You guys wanna have like a painting session again, you know?
some therapy you know oh yeah are you gonna be my therapist
emory oh my god let's see if we can get you i'll fix you oh
my god you're gonna fix me yeah she's perfect she's perfect
why don't you have like you could like dance together like
have like a little dance off and like you know all right oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa.
Yeah, yeah, Gritty Gritty.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Yeah, Gritty, Gritty, Gritty, Minion Gritty, Kirby Gritty.
Oh, yeah, twerking Luigi.
Yeah.
.
Gosh, Naki.
Oh, oh, I didn't mean to do that.
Oh, oh, are you saying something?
No, no, no.
It's because I'm trying to say something, right?
I'm trying to say something, right?
I don't know why I'm not saying that.
Are you putting your face in my butt?
No, I think I know why you die, Emily.
It's because you're dumpy.
The dumpy.
The sound of your ass.
She clapping is gonna alert the dog.
Hey, that's my job.
Let's go to Val.
Alright.
Here we go, guys.
This is it.
We got this.
This is the run.
Alright.
This is it.
Last time when I feel like we're in danger...
Start the ship.
Yeah.
Next time I hear a dog, I will start the ship.
I do not trust dogs anymore.
Don't trust the dog.
Yeah, pretty much.
I do not trust them.
Yeah, I will start the ship as soon as I see a dog hero.
Which way was it again?
Is it this way?
Maybe.
Oh!
Not this way.
Don't go this way.
Don't go that way.
Come back, come back, turn back.
I think it's...
I don't remember.
Come on with a bridge, right?
Maybe it's there.
This way?
Wait, no, not that way.
Nope.
It's a...
I'm lost.
I have no idea.
Where is it?
Oh, it's here, it's here.
Watch out though, watch out.
There's a beehive right next to it.
That's a terrible place for beehives.
Wait,
we can just go to the other bridge.
We can just go to the other bridge.
Oh yeah, over here, over here.
Yeah, the flimsy one.
Alright, I'll go on it.
Go, go, go!
Whoa!
Okay, we're good We're fine.
Little funny hopping.
Let's go!
Intrusive thoughts, because I was on it.
What?
She's real adulting, you know.
Let's go, guys.
Nice.
no was it worth it was it worth it betraying her losing all
the oh present oh gotcha like how you dropped that as fast
as you could just grab it oh nice yay so far a gotcha rate's
been good yeah so far good good I didn't see how much it was
worth though hmm the mod is working.
Maybe it's just not working.
Hmm.
But I think it's pretty exciting anyway.
I'm gonna keep it out, put it outside.
Oh.
Yeah, I'm gonna drop this too.
Damn.
Nice.
Loose.
Here, guys.
Hello.
What's wrong?
I thought we had something together, Naki.
What happened?
Hello?
It's Naki alive?
Oh, it might be the other way.
It might be the other way.
Oh, the other way.
Oh, but there's here, too.
Oh, the apparatus.
We'll have to grab it later.
Oh, yeah.
Over here?
Nothing?
Oh.
There's a dead end.
I hate dead ends.
I don't have anything as well.
Oh, we're back here.
Oh, hello.
I hear them.
Are we taking the apparatus?
Oh, you can be bugged.
Oh, gross.
You can be bugged.
Why don't...
Do we want to...
Ah!
Yippee!
Nope, I didn't get anything.
Let's go through the fire exit instead.
Let's do that, yeah.
Yeah, let's try the fire exit.
Do you want to carry this back or leave it here?
Uh...
I think we should carry it back.
Yeah, I think so too.
Carry it back.
Okay, okay.
I think I think people can hold everything.
Yippee!
Yeah, two people can hold everything.
Maybe two of us can go back.
No, drop that.
Drop that Naki and then pick up that first.
there you go there you go okay i'm going to fire okay let's
go okay all right just kind of just kind of slide down yeah
slide i hope there's no things here
oh oh hardcore oh i think there's something i think he's on
the other side Huh, dummy.
Wait, there's a hairbrush?
Somewhere?
Where is it?
Do you get it?
I scanned the hairbrush somewhere.
Where is it?
One hairbrush?
Oh, where is it?
You see it?
Do you see it too?
No?
Oh, there's a hairbrush over here.
It's on top.
Oh, it's up top.
Yeah.
I got it.
Gonna open this.
Oh.
Yeah, we can grab that.
Wait, I can't tell if that was them or not.
This is a big area.
There should be something here.
There's an engine.
Yeah.
Maybe save the bigger stuff for later.
This area is huge.
Scanning.
Yeah, I'm scanning.
Wait.
Okay, this is finally a dead end.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, then there's no other way.
You have to go back.
Yeah.
Wait.
Uh, no, yeah.
No other way.
Okay.
I'm here.
Yeah.
There's the- Oh, there's something.
Yeah, there's the engine.
Oh, and there's a key too.
This is where I died earlier.
I got it.
I'll get the engine.
Okay.
Okay, I have it.
Nice.
Can go back, maybe.
Is this the way back?
Yeah, this is the way back.
All right.
And there's also this way, too.
I'm going to check it.
No, we haven't gone here yet.
Let's check it out just a little bit.
Oh.
And it's a dead end.
Dead end.
Nice.
We're not going to die, guys.
We're good.
Yeah, I have a hairbrush.
Yeah.
I can protect you with a hairbrush.
You're going to style me.
Oh, there's an egg beetle.
Did we...
Wait, did we come this way?
Wait.
Upstairs, upstairs, upstairs, right?
Yeah, yeah.
No.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Over here, over here.
This way?
It's a dead end!
Wait!
Yeah, I think this is the wrong way.
I think it's on the other side.
Is it other side?
Okay, okay.
other side.
Okay.
Wait, it's not this right here, right?
Maybe it's here?
Yeah, this is the one with the... Did we go here?
Oh, yeah, we went here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think you should trust the other side.
Right over here.
Wait, how do we get here?
Yeah, you go up and then you can go across.
Wait, it's so... Oh, wait, we came from over here, right?
Oh, oh, I don't remember.
I think it was here.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, because the thumper, I can hear him.
Oh, yeah, right, right, right.
Yeah, and it was downstairs.
Right here, right here, right here.
There we go, there we go.
Oh.
At 6 p.m.
Uh-oh.
Is it following us?
No, that's the giant.
We gotta go.
Oh, no.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, oh there's a, there's another beehive, okay, all
right, follow me, way back, it's only seven, there's already
a giant out, oh, oh God, it's over here, where, to a, here,
the ship, yeah, oh God, oh, the giant saw me, I think, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
I think I'm dead.
Wait, I found the ship.
Caught him.
Ah, my hands are full.
Start the ship.
Don't wait.
Good job, good job.
Where's Naki?
I think she died.
I think you died.
She didn't make it.
Oh, she's just not on the screen.
Where'd she go?
He wasn't real.
But I thought we heard her.
We heard her.
Oh, it wasn't her then.
No way.
You did?
I didn't.
Oh, I heard her.
It must have been the thumper, I think.
Yeah.
I'm glad you guys made it back.
Oh, the giant got you.
The giant?
Whoa.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
Oh, that's why you weren't on the screen.
But we're at quota.
We're at quota.
Yeah.
We still got two days.
Okay.
Let's see.
How much money do we need to go to Moon?
We need 600, I'm pretty sure.
Oh my gosh, it's a lot of money.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't think we even make it.
I don't know.
It'll be like...
Oh wait, Rend is 550.
We can.
Oh.
Uh-huh.
That seems more doable if we get like the same amount of
loot again.
Yeah, maybe, maybe.
Okay, okay.
Let's do assurance.
Night.
Okay.
Confirm.
And go.
Yeah.
Good run, good run.
Let's go, guys.
Let's go.
Just gotta keep it up.
Keep it up.
All right, I'm landing.
Mansion is on Renn or Dine?
Oh, okay.
So we have to go to Renn or Dine?
I know.
Okay.
You heard that?
It's probably the...
The voices.
It's the voices.
And then load the kind of glitches in it.
Wait, so...
Rend is 550.
Oh, so we could go to Rend, right?
Okay.
So we just need more money.
Yeah, we just need...
Okay.
Wahoo!
That's easy for us.
Yeah!
Up, up, up, up.
over over over oh it's over here wait an entrance there we
go straight oh yeah you're right oh just uh slide on down we
got this hello mint hello that was fast yeah we're geniuses
we're geniuses i don't remember the yeah what is that oh is
that a oh You guys, I think...
I think those are two...
I think those are two turrets.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'll show you.
There's two of them.
So...
I'm gonna go this way.
Probably.
Oh, we're gonna see.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, there's one more here.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god, we're smart.
There's nothing else here.
We honestly could just take a few things here and then dip
is nothing yeah there's nothing here we can go down yeah we
can go down just be careful oh i didn't start the hairbrush
oh oh this guy um i don't think it's worth it oh i'm stuck
yeah i don't think my donkey's too big i don't think it's
worth it are you guys going back We did nothing like super
I'm gonna go the other way Oh no no There's not much there
Yeah there's nothing We grabbed everything over there Oh
what the heck So we would have to go in the dark But what a
free run Maybe like Maybe like two people waited to ship
Yeah that's what I was thinking I'm gonna take my stuff back
So I have a couple things Okay Actually let me get Wait Ayla
Sama Give me your Give me your Rubik's cube I'll take it
also Yeah get with Oh yeah, also this one.
Oh yeah, yeah, to give it all.
Give it all.
Okay, thank you.
Be careful, Nyaki.
All right, let's go back.
Free Rin will have to wait another day.
All right.
Oh, let go.
Okay.
And it's only 12, so it should be good.
What a thrill.
With darkness and silence through the night.
Oh, scared me.
All right, I'm going to be on Pachero.
You know, I could turn off the things.
50 for the tea kettle.
Oh, 408, you guys.
I think we're going to be able to go.
I think we're going to be able to...
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
How do I turn it off?
Um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um.
Uh, other?
Um, uh, uh, uh, uh, oh, shoot.
What do I, um, um, uh, type the code?
Oh, type the code.
See?
See, too?
They don't realize I turned it off.
Uh-oh, okay, okay.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Type view monitor.
View monitor.
Oh!
That's so awesome.
See you too.
Oh, they're just leaving.
Wow, it's so high-deaf.
Oh, there they are.
Okay.
So have you heard of portable apps?
Of course.
I played portable apps.
What do you mean?
Here they come.
Where
are they?
They should have been here by now.
Um.
Uh.
Elmos World.
You know when I was a kid?
Oh, you found it.
Hello.
Yeah, I could tell.
I was turning off the turret for you guys.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Yeah, we couldn't tell if it was off or not.
Wait, we should have gone.
No, it's okay.
It only lasts for a little bit.
I see.
Apparently, apparently the turrets were turned off.
Yeah, you can turn off the turrets.
No, I know you can't.
I don't know when you turn it off.
Oh, yeah.
That's okay.
Was it when I learned more than...
Is it like a timing thing?
Yeah, it turns off for like a couple seconds.
yeah oh oh was it when it like pointed upwards when the turn
went like oh yeah yeah that might be it oh that might have
been it yeah we noticed that but we weren't sure what it was
doing
okay let's go i think we're good i think oh yeah i think if
we do really well in the next thing we can probably afford
rend in the next uh the next try i think yeah yeah wait why
is like the large axle why is it red okay let's go total
right now it's at 400 yeah nice nice nice oh wow yeah we're
good this is the run just need a bit more just need a bit
more a bit more How am I the laziest?
End of the- Yeah!
How is that possible?
Okay, one day left.
One day left.
How we go?
Let's go, okay, we can only go experimentation or assurance.
So let's just do experimentation.
Yeah, experiment.
Yeah.
Basically.
Mm-hmm.
Eikimasu.
Okay.
Shoop!
Time.
Alright.
Work smarter, not harder.
Exactly, you guys.
Eclipse?
No!
No way.
Wait, what?
It's not Eclipse, right?
No, it's not Eclipse, right?
No, we're good.
We're good.
Yeah, we're good.
No way.
Frame start dropping.
Wait.
Oh.
Yeah, we're good.
You alright?
Like, reform and small.
Okay.
There we go.
I'm sorry.
There you go.
No worries.
What is this building here?
I've never noticed this before.
Whoa.
Oh, what the heck?
Huh?
I've never noticed this before.
What is this?
Yeah.
I'm scared though.
There's trees and stuff in here.
That's spooky.
It's like a haunted house.
Let's just, uh, it's like a, it's like teleport to another
world.
Stick to the plan.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, work smarter.
Yeah, the plan, the plan.
But what's in there?
But, but what's in there?
Oh, we got lost.
That's crazy.
Are you lost?
Naki.
The same one's like the other way.
You okay?
Okay, there they are.
We're good.
Everyone's good.
All right.
And in.
Oh, yield sign.
Nothing
here.
Nothing here.
It's a pretty big room.
Wow.
This planet's holding out on us.
What a waste.
Nice sign.
Nothing here.
Thanks.
I'll go up.
Oh, nothing here.
Yeah, nothing there?
Nothing, hee.
It's a mine, it's a mine I can hear it.
Where was it?
Oh there?
Is it?
You can just scan.
Oh, it's over hei, it's over here.
Okay.
Oh, I don't think it's safe to go over here.
I don't think...
I think it's...
Yeah, we can go here.
I think it's hard to get around it, though.
How are you going to go this way?
It's pretty tall.
Nice.
Oh, dead end.
Dead end.
Down, down.
Down.
I'll go this way.
I'll go...
Okay, I'll go this way.
Okay, I'll do this way.
Uh, there's a lot of ways to go.
Open areas.
I feel like they're just all gonna...
loop around though and oh hi hi it was a dead end there's
another there's another mine all right i'm careful i think
this also loops maybe it might be smart to leave and find
fire at this oh wait where what is this oh there is a door
here there's a door here there is okay yeah yeah over here
oh oh nice Oh, it just looped.
No way.
Wait, where does that key go?
How do we even...
I think we came from up.
I think so too.
How will we even get to the fire exit?
I don't know where it is on this.
We'll try to go outside.
We have to go outside again.
Yeah.
I'm going the right way.
I think you are.
Oh, yes I am.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm just a natural genius.
I think.
Still no free run.
I can't believe we lost.
Oh yeah, of course.
The fire exits right over here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I forgot we were on experimentation.
Yeah.
I forgot.
Wait, did I pass it?
Yes.
So many stairs.
Oh no.
It's already two.
I got nothing except the sign.
I only got this metal sheet, so...
Yeah, we need more if we want to make it to.
Ren.
Next time.
That we'll find.
I think it's possible to find something here.
Oh, the door here?
Oh, Freeran!
Freeran!
Yad!
She came back to us.
Yeah, well, we saw we lost her.
talking about are you guys she came back when we needed her
the most yeah let's go let's go
um i kind of went up there yeah i kind of went some places i
went upstairs yeah i think okay see you oh yeah there's a
tattered metal sheet somewhere oh i think it's upstairs okay
Wait, where is it?
Am I blind, you guys?
I don't see it.
Oh, I hear a cat!
We're gonna get Freerend and a cat!
No way.
Let's do it.
Cat.
Psspsspsspsspsspsspsspsspsspsspss!
Oh, it's Oliver!
Meow!
Oliver, let's go!
Where is he?
I don't...
I don't know.
I don't even know if you found him.
Meow.
Kitty?
Hello?
Where is he?
Oh!
I know, I feel so sorry for him.
Where are you?
Oliver.
Oh, maybe...
Yeah.
Oliver?
I scanned him earlier, but now he's gone where I scanned
him.
Oh, I heard him!
Yeah.
Did I just go in a circle?
What?
Oh my gosh.
Oh wait, maybe in here.
Meow.
Did you go down or off?
I'm down.
Oh.
It's quiet, you guys.
It's a little too quiet.
Meow.
I see the metal sheet.
I can't grab it though.
I know, I can't get it either.
Oh wait, wait.
I got it.
A gamer.
Nice.
But where's Oliver?
Here.
I can hear him.
I want to get him and then we, you know what, I think we
should get him and then actually it's probably really late,
Emory.
I think we should just leave.
Yeah, maybe.
Okay, how do we leave?
I don't know.
Oliver, I'm sorry.
Sorry, Oliver.
I wanted to get you.
Where'd you go?
Oh, that way?
Okay.
I think we went down.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait.
And then which way was it?
This way?
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, it's already six.
We got free run, you guys.
It's okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oliver.
I'm gonna be thinking about Oliver all day today now.
I'm gonna feel so bad.
No creature.
Yeah.
Where are you?
You good?
Oh.
I hope they were dead.
I don't think they were dead.
Oh, they were dead.
Just kidding.
They were dead.
Oh my god.
At least me, my job.
We lived.
Freerun blessed you.
She gave you her blessings.
I didn't think I was going to make it, I'll be honest.
I was so scared.
Oh my god.
519.
How much is...
We're so close.
If only we had gotten all of her, we would have made it.
No, no, no, no.
We could kill someone and sell their body.
But we also lose money, don't we?
Then too?
I
forgot.
I forgot how much you get from killing someone.
I don't know.
Really?
It's only five.
There is only five.
But how much you can sell body for.
Oh, some people said someone said we'll get overtime bonus.
So we might actually make it.
Oh.
Yeah.
Okay.
Nice.
I believe.
Okay.
Oh, you only get five.
Oh, it's only five dollars.
Okay, that's nothing.
Yeah.
Never mind.
I can't believe.
Humans are worthless.
Am I good?
Am I streaming?
I'm back?
Okay.
Oh, the- the...
I had a...
Oh,
watch out!
Watch out!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Alright, go, okay, go, go, okay, good.
Goodbye, free rent.
Free rent!
Bye, free rent!
Buy!
Oh, that was fun!
She'll have free rent !
Free rent!
We had to sell her, you guys, we had to sell her.
She was worth a lot of money.
Desperate times!
Desperate measures!
How much did we make?
Look, everything.
I think so.
We got 300.
We got 371.
Ding, ding, ding.
Oh, okay, nice.
Okay.
One in here.
How much did we get?
Okay.
How much are we at?
We have.
Okay, okay, key.
Overtime bonus, over time bonus.
We're so close.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, wait.
We have to wait for the overtime bonus.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So once I think we take off, then we'll be good.
I think we're gonna make it.
Okay, fingers crossed.
Let's go!
Yes, he got this from Florida, right?
Yeah.
I actually get it.
I hope so.
Okay.
There should be.
Oh, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah!
She was like, she too!
Can we make it?
Yes!
We can go to Rend!
Let's go!
Oh, what did I read?
Wait.
All right, last run, last run?
Yeah, last run.
All right.
All right, and Rend had, like, it wasn't it wasn't eclipsed
or anything, so we're good.
Okay, good, good, good.
Oh, nice, nice.
Let's go here.
Hi.
Let's go!
So happy!
Yeah!
We've been there.
It did so well.
Ooh!
You, you, you, you.
You, you, you.
Nice by friend.
Yeah!
Oh, I'm so excited!
Oh!
Wow!
Alright guys, just follow the lights.
Yeah, just follow the lights.
All right, here we go.
Here we go, everyone!
Follow the lights!
Hopefully it's a mansion.
I work in Lush, right?
Fingers crossed.
Yeah.
Oh, uh, just, uh, it's up here.
It's up here.
Wait.
Yeah, yeah.
Right here.
Here's the door.
Over here.
On.
All right.
Yeah.
We made it.
Goku.
It's actually more creepy.
Oh my god.
I'm not giving it.
I'm not giving up on you.
What is so cool though?
There's scarier monsters in here though, so be careful.
Yeah.
I think there's some new ones too.
Yeah, we still haven't seen the new guy.
Maybe because we haven't, we have to come here.
I think they're here, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
There's the door over here too, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
And then another one.
Oh, there's a hairbrush.
And another one?
Nice.
Oh, I hear a cat!
Oh, I'm back!
We have been seeing a cat for so long, actually.
Oh my god, he's so cute!
It's...
What's your name?
It's Kiki!
Oh my god, Kiki!
Kiki's purring, he's so cute!
Kiki!
Oh, cute, Kiki!
Oh yes, oh yes, flip that cat, flip him, flip him.
We had to go back so rough when you're like, I know.
You're pulling on the tail.
You're stroking it.
Okay, nice.
I think everywhere else is a dead end over here.
Cat acquired.
We have won.
Friendship ended with Oliver.
Kiki's my new best friend.
I think I'm gonna put it outside.
I'm gonna run away.
Oliver wasn't worth it.
Maybe just put him by the door right here.
Oh.
Well, hopefully we see Kiki again.
I hope Kiki is not domesticated so that he doesn't...
Yeah.
So he belongs in the wild.
Let's see up here.
Okay, safe up there.
There's better out there.
Oh, there's the one here.
Different doors.
Travel doors.
Oh?
Wait, did I hear someone talk?
Oh.
There we go.
I think we're all clicking on it.
Silly.
Um, dead end.
Dead end.
Nothing here.
Go back.
The door over here.
The other way.
Over here.
Well, if there's nothing here, then it's just key, I guess.
And the hairbrush.
We can always come back.
We can, like, so we don't have to pay for it again since
we're all...
Okay, I'll go this way.
Is it a loop?
Yes.
Oh, red.
Why is there a lot of doors?
What?
I heard something.
I think Ayla Sama might die.
I heard...
Uh...
Ayla Sama?
Wait!
She's dead, everybody.
How did you die?
Um, there was a...
She goes, ooh, red carpet and then died to a trap.
So, just be careful.
There's some...
There's some traps around, you know?
Okay.
There's a red carpet scary.
Yeah.
Oh my god, I can see her dangling body shadow is so scary.
Oh my gosh.
It's so scary.
Oh my god, it's so scary.
The shadow is so scary.
Oh my god.
Hello, it's me!
I'm real!
Is she real?
Yes, I'm real!
I'm real!
Wait, this one, oh wait, what's that?
Oh, the fireplace room.
Uh-oh, I hear the ambiance again.
The ambiance is starting again.
Hello?
Oh, I don't like the mansion.
Scares me by myself.
Wait, ah!
Wait!
Hello?
Oh, there's the ambience.
What is it?
What is it you guys think?
Do you think it's... Goku?
Goku!
Oh, I'm back here.
Uh, this way.
This way.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
So we just got a little Bracken...
Wait, do I have a girl?
Where's the music coming from?
Where's the girl?
Hello?
Are you guys outside?
No, it is me!
It's me!
The Bracken is ch- What was that?
I just heard someone laugh!
Oh, where are you?
Oh, hello?
Hello?
Oh, that's not heard!
That's not heard!
What?
They sounded so close.
What's that?
Hello?
What's that sound?
What's that thump?
Oh, it's a jester?
Oh god.
It's the jester?
We are so...
Wait, wait.
Kiki!
Uh-oh.
Oh my god.
I thought it was a dog.
that's not you that's not you at all oh my
god oh my god I thought it was like they even responded what
it was crazy no way it was a mimic
oh my god that was so scary what happened wait
No, I thought, well, I was holding the cat and I heard
something behind me and I was like, oh my gosh, a dog is
following me and the cat is going to like, is crying.
And then I turn around and I saw one of you and I think it
had everybody's voice.
And I was like, oh my God, it's just you.
And so, but then I got to the car, I got to the ship and the
dog attacked the mimic at the last second and saved me.
I was like, it was following you.
It was following me.
What?
Oh my God.
That was so freaky.
of dead i was long dead oh my god oh my god nice save he
brought the cat yeah we got the cat wait oh i need to play
with our child he changed colors a little bit there we go
let's be a lighting oh my gosh that was so crazy i got
killed by like mimics or something like i don't know like i
saw i got killed by the jester oh yeah because we saw the
jester how did you oh wait i I saw how you, I was gonna say,
how did you die?
I love the noise.
I watched you die.
No, please go there.
I got distracted by the...
I saw a red car, too.
Yeah, I know.
It was so shiny.
Oh my gosh.
Do you want to try it again?
Do you want to try Renn again?
Yeah.
Yeah, let's go back, okay.
Woo.
Now that we're here.
Oh my gosh, that was so freaky.
That was so crazy timing.
I thought it was one of you.
Oh my gosh, I was fooled.
I was entirely duped.
I didn't know it follows you back.
Yeah, it does.
They follow you all the way here.
That's crazy.
It's very scary.
Oh.
Riding us like you are cruelly.
Okay, let's go.
Oh my gosh, thank you, Lord Croesus.
Are you here?
Yes.
Wait, where is it?
Over here?
Oh, oh, oh, here it is.
I always can't remember where it...
I wonder where the fire exit is for this.
Oh, if there is one.
Oh, there's Freddy!
Oh, my gosh, Freddy faster!
Freddy faster!
Wait, what else am I carrying?
Oh, the hairbrush, I forgot to put it down.
Magic 7-Ball!
Whoa!
It doesn't do anything.
Oh, there's something there.
Watch out for traps.
Oh yeah, true, true, true.
Yes.
Ew, that carpet!
Oh, it's locked.
Oh, really?
Go back.
Yeah, you get some of the more really crazy monsters in
here.
Tell us where we should go.
Out of the way.
Should I go this way?
Should I go up?
I'm going this way.
Oh!
Oh, sorry, that was me.
Oh, what the heck?
Emily.
Hello.
Oh, brass bell!
Wait, oh, I got it.
Oh, nah.
It's just a, oh.
I don't think there's anything else in here.
I'm kind of scared.
Nah.
You go off?
Oh, there's another door over here, but I think it's been
open.
It's beautiful night.
Oh, perfume bottle.
Oh, nice.
Oh, wait.
Whoa.
There's two things here.
Oh, I got a key if we want to open that other door.
Oh, true, true, true.
I'm not key.
Key kettle.
Oh, there's a kettle.
No.
Are you guys upstairs?
I'm not too loose this time.
I hear something.
I do, too.
What do you hear?
Oh, what is that?
Oh, boo.
Oh, she spoke this.
I'm good at that.
The other direction?
Yeah, we can check the locked door.
Was it this way?
I think it was downstairs, right?
Yeah, it was downstairs.
Was it this one?
Yeah, it was over here.
I left it over there.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh.
Another door.
Wow.
Another locked door.
So many doors.
Wow.
Big discovery, guys.
Nice going.
Let's go.
Another door behind.
Nice.
We got a good amount of loot.
Yeah.
Some outside, too.
Have we been here?
We know I'll put stuff outside, actually.
Yeah, yeah.
What was that?
Uh-oh.
I think it's the voice thing.
No, no.
I think I hear the guy.
I, um, the nutcracker.
Oh.
The hoop?
If you see the nutcracker, don't move.
Really?
Oh, really?
Yeah.
I think he's up here.
Should we go?
Did Naki leave?
Where'd he go?
She went ahead.
I think she went outside.
Oh.
Alright, I'll grab the hairbrush.
Okay.
There's some items on the floor here too.
Oh, okay, I can grab them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And we can take them back.
All right.
Okay.
Here we go.
Follow the light.
We have eaten bean.
Following, following.
It's so windy.
Following the light.
I can't see anything in there.
Interesting though.
It's a little safe house.
Follow the light.
Usually they say don't follow the light.
She's not moving.
Yeah, she's not moving.
Wait, where is she?
Haki's not moving.
I don't know.
Wait, was the painting expensive?
Yeah, it was $100.
They usually are, yeah.
Whoa, whoa.
Wait, where did she leave from?
I...
Is this outside?
She's not moving.
I think it's outside.
Yeah, it looks like it's outside.
But how did she die?
I don't know.
We have a lot of money.
You want to go?
Or do you want to go look for her?
Like, we can probably go and then just come back again.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, it could have been the ghost girl.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot about, like, the...
Oh, someone says it looks like she found the fire exit and
then fell.
Oh, fuck.
Whoopsie.
To hip it out.
Yeah, I think we could go and then just come back.
again we we looted a lot okay ghost girl i want to say the
ghost girl yeah i saw her before she killed me wait she
killed you yeah i think i died from ghost girl before like
earlier she like no no no uh when i played before oh okay
okay ah all right it was like a jump scare kill too came out
of nowhere oh my gosh freaky she like makes you go insane
and then Welcome back.
Welcome back.
I accidentally used Easter egg and it threw me...
Wait, it can do that?
It exploded!
Oh yeah, it'll explode sometimes, yeah.
Naki's gotcha pool.
Okay.
Last run.
Maybe that's what I died to last time.
I was carrying an Easter egg.
and I think it might have exploded on me just randomly.
I didn't know.
You explore yourself.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, maybe that's what it was.
In case I don't come back.
Oh, that's what it was.
I love you, Kiki.
In case I don't come back.
See you later.
I'll be here.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah.
You gotta go up.
Wait.
Yeah, yeah.
You're right.
All right.
Right here.
Can I go too far?
Oh, it's here.
It's so hard to see.
Oh, man.
This is not a mansion.
Wait, there's a comedy mask somewhere.
Where is it?
I scanned it.
Oh, oh, oh.
Where'd it go?
For a comedy.
Maybe it's like on a ledge.
Maybe.
Wait, where'd it go?
Wait, who picked it up?
Someone picked it up.
I'm picking it up.
Not me.
I have a hairbrush.
Mm-hmm.
sauce sauce i should not just see things sauce hello hello
did you pick up a mask yeah there's nothing here no all
right maybe the mask is just flying around it was there yeah
it might be now it's good how suspicious and This is when
the imposter is sus!
Amogus!
Was there anything going on?
Oh, we went here already.
Yeah, oh yeah.
Okay, the other way, the other way.
Other way!
Let's go!
Hmm.
Another maze.
Maze after maze after maze.
Oh, hello.
Um.
Oh.
No, I think- I think we can walk around it.
Maybe.
Sometimes we can.
Is it my Mimi?
Hello?
Oh, hello.
Hi.
Are we going in circles?
It's- Oh, there's a painting!
Oh, that's just somewhere near.
Wow, good job.
There's like nothing here.
Whoa.
But there's a painting.
That's where the lawn.
Yeah, usually.
Yeah.
All right, now we just gotta find a way out.
Oh, there's a key, yeah.
Oh, there's a key.
I might be grab it.
I got it.
It's so hard to see.
Can we go through this door?
I don't think we're going to.
Is that a chase here?
It looks a little foggy.
Yeah.
Nah, I don't think we want to here.
Um, I went in.
Whoa.
Ah.
Let's, maybe we can find the thing.
What's that sound?
Um, um, um, um, um.
I don't have to be good.
I turned it off!
Oh, nice!
Oh, good job, good job.
Cool.
Now I can't- Oh, no.
Uh, I think we're really- I think we're really lost.
I think we're really lost.
Uh oh.
Somewhere close.
Oh, there you are.
Are you loud?
Yeah, we've been following you.
One
second.
No, this is where we came from, right?
Over here?
Maybe.
I was going back to find you guys.
Oh, oh.
Maybe.
Oh, there's a dead end here.
Haha.
Yeah, it sure looks like the area we looked around earlier.
No.
I knew that was a dead end.
I was just confirming.
Here!
Oh!
That's where we came from?
No, there's two.
Oh!
Maybe we can just go back where we came from.
Can we even go back?
I don't even know how to...
Got some bottles?
New area.
They're not gonna follow?
Trust your nose.
Oh, hair dryer!
Big bolt?
Oh, there's a lot here.
Are you real?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, hello.
Yeah, yeah, I thought you weren't.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, there's all the items!
Bottles!
You can get that.
Yeah, yeah.
That's hair dryer?
That bottle?
Oh, that doesn't work!
It actually works.
Yeah.
I think I hear something, though.
That's so cool.
Yeah, we should probably Try to find a way out.
Yeah.
Wherever it is.
There's sometimes a fire escape over here.
Oh, there's a present!
There's a present!
Give bombs, though.
Gotcha, I can't hold it.
Yeah, I can't hold it.
Oh, I'm under hairbrush.
Under hairbrush?
What is that?
Um, um, um, um, um.
What's there?
Um.
The brachan?
We riding it?
Is the brachan?
Go-go-go-go-go.
We have to go back.
Oh, okay, okay.
Goku?
It's to our left.
Should I open?
I have really...
Kind of like doing Quiddick's mode.
Open it!
Yeah, open it!
Alright.
Yeah!
Another hair dryer.
Oh my gosh, wait.
How do we leave?
Um...
Oh my god.
There's a...
Oh.
He's opening the door.
What?
Who opened the door?
Why the was over there?
Um...
You guys see that?
See what?
Why?
It was a ghost girl!
You saw a ghost girl!
Oh, that's only you, I lost your life.
It's a ghost girl?
It's only for me?
Yeah.
No, that's only for you.
Oh!
I see you!
Uh-oh.
It's your egg!
Oh no, it's a-
I'm coming with you!
Go, go, go, go!
I
can't help you!
No, I'm gonna die to the trap!
No!
I'm ready!
I got it!
Kiki!
Yeah, that's crazy.
The
bugs came down from the ceiling.
It's stuck out there.
Oh my god.
We even made the jump!
Oh my gosh!
That was so crazy.
It was a lot.
Did the ghost girl killed you?
Yeah, it killed me, the ghost girl.
Yeah.
Three different things.
I know.
That's because you're paranoid.
Like, they're all hugging you.
I couldn't continue forward because the trap would have
crushed me and then the two mimics were blocking the other
way.
I saw.
This is not just me and a mimic.
What the heck?
I hope Kiki gets lots of love wherever they go.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, Kiki.
Aw.
Oh no!
It's okay.
We were doing so well.
Yeah, we were.
Oh well.
Well, maybe you'll find another Kiki.
Yeah!
Find another Kiki.
Can I go the same place?
Oh yeah!
This is to you, Rend.
Sorry.
Oh wait, no, we have to go sell now.
Never mind.
No, it'll let us, right?
It'll let us.
Oh, it will let us.
Yeah, yeah, we just got to hold it down.
Yeah.
One more mention.
Outing.
Maybe we'll get the new monster.
I hope so.
No free run, no geeky.
We lost them all.
It's eclipsed?
Oh, we're so, we're so boned.
Oh, is it?
Oh, wow.
What?
Is it eclipsed?
Is it?
Yeah.
Wait, do you see the moon?
This might be the best run yet.
Yeah, it's an eclipse!
Last one, best run!
Last one, best run?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go!
Killed in!
No, he's not getting killed.
I don't trust Eclipse.
Whoa, it's so dark in here.
It's so dark in here.
Yeah, yeah.
I thought you died.
No.
Because it's Eclipse, I was like, I was trying to be sneaky.
Oh.
High voltage.
We can turn on it.
Wait, maybe we can turn the lights on.
Oh, yeah.
Maybe we can make a picture.
Yeah, yeah.
How do we do this?
Flip switch.
Switch, yeah.
E.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, open the light.
Oh, yeah, we got some lights on.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
Nice, nice.
Kind of spooky, though.
Mamma Mia.
Oh man.
You're not my brother.
Oh, there's just a single key in the middle of the floor.
Oh, the heck, that's ominous.
Whoa.
Okay, I grabbed it.
Nice.
Mission accomplished.
Whoa.
It's a really big chair.
Scanning, scanning, where we had it.
Oh, it goes around, okay.
Oh, this is where we came from.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go down.
Yeah, go down.
Okay.
Maybe we'll have some lights on now and over here.
Oh, where am I?
Where am I?
The main room.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, this looks right.
Right?
There's the main room.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we got the lights.
Oh, there's bottom lights.
Oh, didn't even notice it.
Okay.
We locked doors.
Oh, there's Freddy.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
It's Freddy.
Hey boo!
Oh my god!
The precious thing!
Minto stole the precious thing!
There we go There we go I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm I'm starting one
can't be I leave without you Why don't you love me?
Why don't you love me?
Here, someone else wants her.
Guys, Naki died.
Did Naki die?
Yeah.
Might have.
I hear him.
Oh.
Do I live with Raimu or...
Nah, we're gonna go back in.
If I die...
I don't think this area...
Yeah, this...
Oh no!
There's also the Yippies!
Wait, what's this?
Oh, there's just another vent.
The Yippies are also on the loose.
Maybe that's why there's no items.
Why is there music?
It's so scary for no reason.
Oh, it's a lot.
Wait.
Oh, I had a key.
I think in the last life.
You guys heard that music, right?
What the heck was that?
It was like a...
What was that sound?
Do you guys actually not hear that?
hear the ambience?
I mean, I think I do have the game kind of turned down
low-ish because the voices can get kind of loud, but maybe
I'm the only one hearing the ambience.
See, you can't hear that?
What is that sound?
That is cheap.
Are those teeth in the middle of a trap?
I got my choppers.
You can't scare me.
Oh.
My choppers!
You can't scare me.
What am I hearing?
Actually, I have no idea what I'm hearing.
You guys heard the slimy thing too, right?
Am I going crazy?
There's actually nothing here.
He's a janitor!
Wait!
I'm a maid!
Wait, what is he?
He's a butler.
Ah!
He will kill if you are alone.
That's so evil.
Oh my gosh, I've never seen him before.
Oh my god.
I'm actually not sure if he's a new guy or not.
But he seems new.
Doesn't seem like a mod.
He's not following me right here.
out kind of sounds like bug screw like scrittling around
i don't know why they're dead i have no idea it's okay don't
it doesn't matter if we grab anything it was the last day it
doesn't matter but that's true let's go yay i got to the dog
yeah Yeah, we got Raimu though.
I'm glad you saved her.
Can I die with Raimu?
You did what you do.
Sister.
Bye everybody.
Bye Raimu.
Goodbye everybody.
It was nice knowing you.
Oh!
Raimu!
She left me.
No!
Raimu.
Goodbye.
15 deaths.
Wowie.
Wow.
This is so fun, you guys.
That was fun.
It was so much fun.
Good, yeah.
Did you guys see the butler from my POV?
I did, yeah.
Ricky.
He's so ugly.
He did the stabby stabby.
Yeah, he was ugly.
Oh my gosh.
oh so fun oh yeah we played so much we did for real oh my
gosh i just realized what time it is oh my god it's a toy
yeah we've been playing for four hours i'm really grateful
yeah i'm really so much for playing yeah already wow yeah
get some rest everybody yeah you too guys you guys want Um,
if there's anything to say before we end, maybe we could
take turns Okay, like any announcements All these things
Ammo Me?
Me?
Yeah All right Thank you, everyone for playing with me.
I know I um kind of put this collab together last minute But
yeah, I think Natsuki and I'm an instrument for all green to
play with me today and join in.
And I'm glad we got to do some big and fun before Naki's
hiatus as well.
Don't mention me.
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry.
I said it wrong.
That was the wrong question.
All right.
In terms of upcoming streams for me, I'm playing a rage game
tomorrow called Simple Fish Game.
I think it's a rage game.
So I'm going to come see me rage.
Come watch me tomorrow.
And also, I'm Sunday.
I'm doing it by the way.
I'm playing Professor Layton's songs if you're a fan of the
series, come watch!
Let's go!
Yeah!
Thank you!
We share this up to all the lovely girlies here!
Yeah!
Pachi!
Oh!
Excuse me?
Um, I'm sorry.
Yeah, you better apologize.
I apologize.
Okay.
next oh i think i think i last summer oh me okay wait um for
me i only have a stream tomorrow it's gonna be 3d cleaning
up my room nothing special just me literally cleaning up my
room productive nothing special productive productive stream
yeah i don't have anything going on to announce but to say
thank you to everybody who joined and thank you to those
lovely ladies for playing with the ariato now yeah thank you
next oh okay the maid okay um big boss hold on um oh thank
you guys for with me it's a lot of fun i had i really
enjoyed being able to collab with you again emily and
collabing with you aila sama and naki for the first time was
so much fun but i'm glad that we could play before your
hiatus naki yeah yeah big boss gritty i'm always down to
hang out more Yeah, yeah, I can't stop.
Wait, I can't stop.
Okay, I can't stop the gritty.
Wait.
Oh, oh, oh, there we go.
Oh, thank you.
All right.
Last but not the least.
You.
I just want to say, I love you guys so much.
I'm very happy I get to play with you guys today, and I'm
happy.
happy that i'm happy i very like to just support that would
make me happy yeah there
we go good luck
yeah always support you but i got to hang out with you thank
you
so much for all the fun today oh my god it's so fun yeah i
hope you guys like the mods Yeah.
I had so much fun.
Me too.
Definitely made the game less scary.
Yeah, the game crashed only once before it played.
Yeah.
It's all good.
All good.
No Goku, but it's okay.
I know.
Next time.
I don't think it's working.
I don't think so either.
At least it didn't crash.
It was an update.
Oh yeah.
All right.
I'll see you guys around.
See you around.
I am.
Good luck.
Love you all.
Oil to the mission, everybody.
M ganze!
Mesh!
Bye-bye!
oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Where's your sweet spoon?
Touch-butt, I guess.
Oh, yeah, yeah!
Touch-butt.
Vo !
I cannot even see him!
Yeah, I can just imagine it.
It's okay, it's not the exact sign.
Oh my god, you guys are really, you were really on top of
each other.
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go talk to my chat a little bit now.
Same here.
Okay.
Bye bye everyone!
Bye bye!
Yay!
Let me...
Maybe...
Let me change some stuff on my...
my it's just frozen there change some stuff there we go yeah
yippee yippee yippee welcome back boys thank you oh my game
is not responding anymore my my game is not responding
that's fine look it's a nice little screenshot of the three
of us Well, the three, the four of us, I'm not in the
picture though.
Oh, there we go.
That was so fun.
Oh my gosh.
I've never played with the mods before.
I don't know what mods we had.
Hold on, I think I can check.
There's so many that it's like, let's see.
We have more suits, more emotes, yippee.
Flashlight toggle.
I don't know what's on that.
Better item scan, better stamina, skin walkers, push to
mute, um, a couple patch things, helmet cameras, walkie use,
I don't, we never use a walkie, so, needy cats, it's, hey,
it's me, Goku, it doesn't work, so sad, Metal Gear sneaking
theme, lethal clunk, which was the, my, the pipes, um,
lethal presence, which was the present, what's more screams?
Modification allows you to hear players' voice for two
seconds after they die.
Oh, cool.
Yeah, it says adds the hey it's me Goku audio to the bracken
whenever it hunts you.
And he was hunting me.
He was.
Lethal plushies is the one that adds the free-rin plush and
stuff.
And big boss suit.
A lot of this was Emuri, too.
She, like, found all the mods, basically.
Well, my friend gave me some mods, and then we kind of added
more to it.
But Emuri, like, tested everything and made sure it was,
like, not going to crash.
Like, unfortunately the Minecraft one didn't work.
It was going to add, like, a Minecraft map.
But if only we had played right before...
If only we had played before the update.
But that's okay.
The big boss suit?
Yeah, that's what I was wearing the whole time, but you
couldn't see.
I should have asked someone to put it on so I could see what
it looked like.
Okay, I'm going to have to go see their VOD so I can see
what it looked like.
That was so much fun.
Man.
Glad that I could play with everyone.
So, yeah, thank you again, MOD, for setting this up.
And I'm glad that I could play with Naki before her hiatus.
Um, play with Ayla Saman.
Yeah.
I'll catch the bots too.
Yeah, everybody's super duper awesome.
They're all my friends.
So, really happy.
I got to hang out with Emory a couple times in Japan.
So, um, yeah, I'm glad that even after all this time we've
been able to, you know, hang out and be friends and do
everything.
Yeah, we're friends.
We're friends.
It was a lot of fun.
Yeah, I hope you guys had fun.
There was some really funny moments.
I cannot believe that.
That mimic round.
Where I thought it was one of that.
You know why I thought it was one of them following too?
Because none of them crouch.
None of them crouch when they're walking outside sometimes.
So it's just like.
So I was just like.
Oh, and then it also had Emudy's voice.
She's just being quiet because she's trying to, you know,
avoid the dogs, but she said like, hey, like, you know, she
said something.
So I was like, oh, it's just Emedy.
That was so crazy.
And the shadow was cast on her, so I would have never seen
the, the, the face.
I never saw the face.
That was so, it was creepy.
I think that was the creepiest moment I've ever had with the
Mimic.
Skinwalker mod really pulled through in that moment.
I know.
gosh you are actually super cracked at this game stop it no
i'm not stop it i hope oliver is doing okay we looked for
oliver we really did i wonder where that guy went i hope
he's okay oliver thank you guys for all the donos and super
chats and everything while i was playing sorry that i
couldn't reach out so much because you know with a collab
especially like this kind of game do but um hopefully you
guys didn't feel too neglected um but yeah it was so much
fun oh my gosh thank you for the stream then kiki moved out
no we we abandoned kiki not like we missed you or anything
shut up you shut up streamer didn't read message it's over
it's over it's over but it's a m for me and tomorrow i have
a long stream so um i didn't expect to be playing for four
and a half hours um but we were just having so much fun yeah
i'm from ilas thank you for the very fun collab oh thank you
thanks for dropping by appreciate it so much fun thank you
thank you um but yeah uh what was i gonna say yeah tomorrow
will be um will be Twin snakes, I already have the waiting
room up because I had to move the times around a little bit.
But I have a vlog stream tomorrow, so I should get some rest
tonight.
Wow, this talk, thanks for the gifted!
Wireson, thanks for the super chat!
Don't worry, oh, sorry.
I won't read this.
I was really from watching you guys.
I put you on the background while I was making pickled eggs.
It was hard not laughing.
Good night, thanks for the stream.
Aw, thank you.
Are you going to finish Twin Snakes next stream?
I don't know.
We'll see.
I might go crazy and try and finish it.
I still...
I'm what?
Like...
I'm not halfway.
Am I halfway?
The briefings did take a good chunk of time.
It always takes 40 minutes.
I'm past half, for real?
Oh.
I always think of...
It's funny, because I always think of, like, the switching
of the CDs as halfway.
Yeah, Disc 2 has halfway, but it's actually not really.
I almost always miss my chance to catch these live, but
today was the day!
JL, thank you!
Congrats for your awesome game.
Wow, thank you so much.
Meryl Silverberg.
Thank you for the fun Lethal Company collab.
A lot of funny moments.
Looking forward to your next Metal Gear Solid stream.
Can I hardly wait?
I've been thinking about...
Oh my gosh, I've been thinking about, um, about, uh, about
Twin Snakes, like, all week.
I was just like, maybe I should move it sooner.
Maybe I should move it sooner.
Every time I play Metal Gear, I just want to play, I just
want to, I just always can't wait for the next time I play
it again.
Does Twin Snakes also have the disc switch?
It does, yeah, it does.
Um, I have, uh-oh.
You can hear it.
I have disc two right here.
So disc one is obviously in my GameCube at the moment.
But I was thinking about April 30th.
I think I have another plan for April 30th.
What I kind of want to do instead of just play.
Because I was thinking of like starting or like doing kind
of marathoning.
Metal Gear Solid 2 and finishing on April 30th, but I do
have another plan of something I kind of want to do
involving April 30th Metal Gear related.
And once I do plan on replaying all most, if not all, the
games.
So at least like, you can definitely expect me to play MGS1
through Peace Walker at least because I have some plans so
but I do plan on playing them on streaming them so yes 5 is
a long one to replay that's the only one I'm debating but at
the same time I might get to the end and I might be like,
man, I gotta play it.
So, usually miss your streams, but your current schedule
actually got me finally catching your streams.
Oh my gosh, Strike Warlock!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Will you be playing all of the Metal Gear games so we can
experience the Brain Rot a second cough, cough, burst time?
Of course.
So, Revengeance again?
Revengeance will be at the end.
I'll actually play it in order.
Not that I...
Well, I mean...
I...
I mean, when I first played them, I kind of played, you
know...
I played it, you know.
Well, you know...
Stop!
You guys stop!
You guys suck.
Oh, great stream.
Trying to catch more live, but the mods help me get through
work.
No, I appreciate you watching the mods.
so much.
Thank you so much, Kangaroo wife.
Especially looking forward to the MGS stream.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
You made us like this?
I didn't do anything.
Played it in heaven, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, in heaven.
Release order or chronologically?
I did think about playing it chronologically, but I don't
think I...
I don't know.
I really feel like playing it in release order.
order just feels you know the bestest even though i've
already played it in release order and everything phd
killers welcome back oh my gosh five months wait it kept up
it kept the initial stuff too thanks for the chaotic collab
boss thank you that's so awesome this is such a fun stream
to watch thanks to you and the others so happy you're here
thank you shy thank you Yeah.
MGS3 hits harder if you played in release order.
Agreed.
You know guys, I've been thinking a lot about it.
Avoid MGS5.
I have issues.
Really Huey.
You have issues?
Really.
Oh my gosh, we die!
Thanks for the hot dog.
What was I gonna say?
Oh, I've been thinking so much about, I don't know,
Recently, I think it's because I was like April 30th is
coming up.
For a long time, I was like, MGS3 is my favorite Metal Gear.
MGS3 is my favorite one.
MGS3 is like, I just love everything about MGS3.
But now, I think I've changed my mind.
And I think I've changed my mind for like, for good.
Because I always would kind of be like, 3 is so awesome.
3 is my favorite.
It's like neck and neck, you know?
But now I think, honestly, 2 is my favorite.
I think 2 is my favorite.
And then 2 is Peace Walker.
And then 3.
Isn't that so crazy?
2 is just special.
I think there's like a weird sense of nostalgia that I feel
with 2, even though I never played it as a kid.
Like, the ending of...
of MGS3 obviously hits, but like there's something about the
ending of MGS2 that hits even harder.
I don't know.
Okay, so Pliskin on side B.
Lulu!
You're...
Oh my gosh.
First of all, you are so fast.
Second of all, I didn't think you were... Like, I was not
serious.
I didn't think this would actually happen if it's actually
happening.
And three!
Oh my gosh!
He looks so good!
He looks so good.
You're incredible.
You're amazing.
The handshake and the moment that hits me the hardest in
this series ever no man i love mgs i just mgs too i love it
love metal gear solid i love metal gear solid too ending is
so insane that it's more memorable i think so i think also
because like obviously i was like oh my gosh kind of
brainwraited from from metal gear solid but like metal gear
solid too made me be like like i i would was hook line
sinker i was i was in deep i was not coming out i dug my
grave i dug it i i dug it six feet under i was i was already
i could not climb out of that even if i tried i was the big
hook yeah mint loves mgs shocked adam bomb welcome to
membership thank you so much i need to explain to me it was
so wild we can talk about it next time i play it
my brain rot is never going away i got some more metal gear
goods in today
uh which one of them was um you know i never actually had
the soundtrack for for metal gear solid 2 like i have i have
like a bunch of cds and some of them contain like music from
the games but um I don't have like dedicated CDs for each
game except two I finally could find that one but I need to
find like a CD like the ones I have of three are like oh
this is different variations of Snake Eater um but um I want
like the actual game music soundtrack you know in terms of
gameplay I think 5 is my favorite or my favorite is five but
i love them all oh yeah the gameplay in five is phenomenal
phenomenal it's so fun it's so awesome mgs2 is more locked
to my brain than any other game in the series i think so for
me too i think mgs2 has the most memorable memes for me but
mgs3 is my favorite story i can i can get with that but even
for two like three i love quoting so much i'm always like i
want some more I don't know.
The two is just...
It's just something about it.
Like I said, it makes me feel nostalgic in a way that...
I shouldn't feel nostalgic for, but...
I do.
I don't know.
I also really like stories that take place...
at the ocean.
Like, uh...
Like, I'm...
I love the beach so much.
I love the ocean.
And so, like, one scene that, like, really sticks out to
me...
is um is when emma and ridden are when she's about to like
when when she's about to you know get attacked by vamp but
like when they're climbing down the the ladder and like then
they walk outside and like it's just the sunset and they're
just looking over the water and i'm like it's so beautiful
so so visually beautiful and orange
Manage to avoid drowning.
The ocean is so comfy.
It is.
I don't have like, I know some people have like that fear of
the ocean, the deep ocean, but...
Who is vamp?
This is vamp because he's a vampire?
Oh my gosh, next time I play, I have to get that codec.
It's so fun using the mic on E.E.
and hearing her complain.
There's just so much in this area.
Sorry, I know I'm always talking about Metal Gear.
Can't help it.
I can't help it.
It's because I have no one else to talk to about it.
So I'm like overflowing.
Whenever I meet with my friend Maddie.
Oh, that's Raspberry.
I'm just like...
We are just like non-stop.
Like...
Because she and I share this same brain ride.
It's so...
And it's so nice.
It's so awesome.
I really want to play Resident Evil next so that I can
also...
So I can also talk to her about it.
So I don't plan on playing through the series again.
Like, not super soon.
Soon-ish.
Maybe I'll probably start it this year.
I mean, it's only April.
But, yeah.
You have to get into No More Heroes.
Yeah!
I do.
So I can talk to her about that, too.
Yeah, I think you'll have a lot of fun playing Resident
Evil.
Yeah, I hope so.
I have no clue about MGS, but I'm happy to have the chance
to know about it with your second playthrough.
Oh, Raisin!
Yes!
I hope you like it as much as I do.
So, oh boy.
This is gonna be good.
Resident Evil also has some great deep lore to uncover, but
not as much as the Fungi Game Meta Universe Mono.
What the... Those were words that you strung together?
Yes.
Original or remakes for the first four REs?
I don't really want to play the first Resident Evil
original.
I don't know.
Have you played any Resident Evil game before?
I've only played a little bit of Resident Evil 1 the
original.
The game company.
All their games are connected.
Got it.
From what I understand is the remakes for Resident Evil are
all pretty good.
From what I understand.
I think.
Hey, Bubba Girl.
Hey, Kami's Prize, Mint's...
Thieve.
It cuts off.
Liam, thank you.
I enjoy hearing you talk about MGS.
It's how I am about Dragon Age and Mass Effect and Ace
Combat to a lesser degree.
It's fun to be super into something, right?
All the remakes except three are good.
Okay.
RE3 and 4 are downgrades for me.
See I heard a lot of people say RE4 remake is pretty good.
But I had not heard about 3.
3 is a bit bare bones.
3 is just short.
I don't know.
I played any Castlevania before?
I have played Symphony of the Night.
Yes.
Okay.
I should really go to bed since it's almost 3 a.m.
really go to bed.
Thank you guys for sticking around.
I really want to talk more because we haven't been able to
talk the whole time, but I should really go to bed.
We'll talk a lot more tomorrow when I play stuff.
Yeah, I'm planning to buy Metal Gear Series.
Any suggestions which one I should start with?
By the way, Otamito!
Double Dissol!
Thank you!
Start with Metal Gear Solid!
All you gotta do is start with number one.
Fake meet that guru It's great to see you collab with Emery
again And Aila and Naki too Yeah So fun They're such great
girlies Okay Otsuminto everybody Otsuminto Thank you so much
Thank you Thank you thank you Thank you Aileen thank you
Have you done your homework for this week My homework I had
homework Late night mint is a real treat Thank you for the
stream Nixitama, thank you.
If only this was, like, Friday night, maybe it would be
better for some people.
I know maybe some of you might have work tomorrow.
Please, please get some rest.
And I'll see you guys with Twin Snakes.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye.
You know what?
I'm not even gonna do the outro because the song is kind of
loud.
I'm just gonna quit.
I'm just gonna stop from here.
So we're not even gonna do the outro.
I'm just gonna leave here.
So, Otaminto!
Otaminto, otaminto!
ozuminto bye bye bye thank you guys so much get some rest
get some rest drink water stand up stretch see you bye bye
oh my oh it's a minto bye bye bye bye bye bye